From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, we're ready.
Today is Thursday, September 1, 2011.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer John Bishop.
And we are in the field today to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And we're delighted to be in Oakland at the offices of the Black Alliance for just immigration with Mr. Phil Hutchings.
Thanks so much for sitting down.
It's a pleasure that they be under the building.
You caught me.
Let me start. Let's just for a few minutes talking a little bit about your family in Cleveland and coming up there.
And obviously that would be some of the on trade to all your later civil rights and other work.
Maybe just have you talked a little about your folks and coming up in Cleveland?
Well, my folks were migrants to Cleveland.
My dad is from Macon, Georgia.
I just visited there pretty recently about a week ago.
And he, as a young man, I'm not sure exactly how old he was.
His dad and his mother divorced.
And she stayed in Georgia and his father went up to Cleveland as part of the Northwirt Migrations and got a job as a street car conductor on Leole Trackless Trolleyes.
And by the end, it's followed him.
I don't know exactly.
A bunch of questions you'd love to ask later and never got around to asking at the time.
So I don't know exactly.
But he came as a young man somewhere to Cleveland.
My mom was born in a little town outside of Memphis, Tennessee, Union City.
And her mother died when she was about a year old.
And so she was passed to one of the sisters, one of our mother's sisters, her aunt.
And the aunt lived in Cleveland and was a maid in Cleveland.
And so my mom came at a very young age.
She was too young to be even aware of it probably.
To Cleveland and lived out in Cleveland Heights for the most part.
She moved around as her aunt got different jobs.
So there's a lot of interest right now because there was a domestic workers' bill of rights that was passed in New York State about a year or so ago.
And there's one pending in the California State Legislature.
So they're trying to look at what has been the history of domestic workers over time.
And I just said, oh, my mother wasn't a domestic worker.
But she was the woman who raised her, was, and she used to live in the house where her mother worked as a maid.
How interesting was that?
Tell me something about that.
Oh, so I should just say that around that, they were, I would call, lower middle class.
My dad worked at the post office as a clerk, pretty much all his work life.
In the mid-50s, he did get a job as a salesman for something called Kaiser Frazier.
You're probably old enough to know what that was.
And that, with belly up, not too long afterwards.
So I think that basically said, I better go back to the government where there's always a current job.
And again, one of these questions you never asked is, I'm sure a lot of that thinking was shaped by the depression.
And again, it's something we never, ever talked about.
But at a time in the 50s, we're in late 50s, particularly where some of his friends were beginning to become doctors or lawyers and professionals.
I think about buying their house.
He kind of stuck in where he was, where he felt they were sure to, assurance as a postal clerk.
So it meant being a postal clerk that he was governed by something called the Hatch Act,
which means that as a US postal worker, he couldn't be political activists.
So he had a lot of interest in a lot of the questions of the day, but that's why he did it through the church.
And there was this social and literary forum called the St. James Forum, which was not our particular church actually.
But I'm not quite sure of the politics, but he became sure of that for a couple years.
And it's a little boy, I would go to some of those meetings and there would be local politicians are talking about issues.
So on one hand at a very early age, I got some sense of the bigger world.
And they were coming right to a church right in our general neighborhood in Cleveland.
And I remember meeting the late Senator Robert Taft, who was from Ohio in 1952.
I was all of eight years old.
And Taft was running for the Republican nomination against Eisenhower, which he eventually lost.
But as the home senator, he was going around.
And the church was one of the places where a lot of the white politicians came to talk to parts of the black consistency.
And so St. James was one of the leading churches for that.
And so they got a really good sort of, I remember shaking Robert Taft's hands.
And I said to my dad, I said, Dad, you know, he's got the most on the softest hands.
I had shook hands with him. I'm eight year old.
And my dad, he was a Democrat, a queer, I said, yeah, because he's never done a real days of work in his life.
And so, okay.
So my dad was active at that level.
And he was a decadent in the church, but he was restricted in terms of his politics.
So I would always thought about him.
He was a kind of Humphrey, he was a Humphrey Democrat in the late 50s, early 60s.
My mom, as she grew up, she became a social worker.
And then she eventually went to law school.
And she had the good fortune.
It was one of those days where there were so few blacks moving ahead at that level that the small circles of people knew each other.
So she ended up going to law school with Carl Stokes, who became the first black mayor of Cleveland.
And when he became mayor, he actually appointed her the chief referee of the Civil Service Commission.
And being a typical, I mean, my mind was in the South, what was happening in the Civil Rights Movement.
And I guess I wasn't aware that much later on how critical a job that was,
because they were trying to integrate or desegriate the better word, the fire department and the police.
And so it was very much a hot seat job.
And so, but I never, again, at the time, was not totally aware of a lot of the stuff that she was having to deal with and go through
and Stokes being the first black mayor.
It was just a lot of kind of almost like Obama being the first black president.
So it was a really time for them. But as a kid, they kind of shielded that.
I was aware of it, but not really aware of the deep details.
And so, they were very interested. My dad, we used to listen to Lowell Thomas on the radio as a kid.
And we had one of those old-fashioned globes on a stand.
And after the Lowell Thomas was over, we'd go over to the globe.
And there was something about Iran, he'd show me where it was, or Cuba.
So I sailed that to say that I was getting a sense of the world.
And it was right in the family. And some of the local things, there was nothing radical about Lowell Thomas.
But at least it was the news. And Cleveland, I think, always felt itself kind of the more liberal part of the state of Ohio.
And it tended to look east toward New York, as opposed to west to Chicago.
And so there was a kind of liberalism in the air.
There was a very kind of liberal Jewish community in Cleveland.
At least at that time, I'm not too familiar with what's going on more currently.
And there was a lot of ethnic diversity, mostly Catholic.
And people from Eastern Europe.
And then you had a very heavy, oriented Democratic Party machine, which most of the time I was a kid, was controlled by the Irish.
So if you were old, anything, or you could say what county you were from in Ireland, you had jobs like that, you know.
And my mom did get into the infrastructure a little bit in the Democratic Party.
She actually ran for state representative. And she got endorsed by the local paper at the time at Cleveland Press.
And she did quite well for her first time around.
She came in, I think, about 20th. And there were the first 18 with the ones who got nominated on the Democratic's slate.
I think it was 58. It was either 56 or 58. I'm not quite remembering.
So I was in high school, and so my mom was running.
And I helped her from the very beginning. She ran originally for a precinct committee, and the district kind of...
Mirror our greater neighborhood. And I was a paper boy for the Cleveland playing dealer, which still exists.
And so I just put her campaign stuff in all the papers, especially the Sunday paper, where it was really big and stuff like that.
And then when I went to collect money, I'd say, don't forget my mother, who she's running for this, and blah, blah, blah, blah, we would like your vote.
So that was some of my first little grassroots kind of political activity, and very local.
And then the other piece I mentioned that, because I hadn't thought about it for years, was...
Some of our parents wanted us to do something civic. We didn't even use the word political.
I don't know if that was from the McCarthy period or what, but it was civics and civic interest group.
And so they got a group of young people together and tried to figure out what to do.
And I found this word called archegos, which in Greek, I've never looked it up since then, since the 50s.
It's something about civic duty or something being part of the polity of the society.
And so we named the archegos club, and to save my life, I couldn't remember exactly what we did back those years.
But we did meet, we did do the local projects, and raised money here and there.
And then the other piece was for me during that time period, was the...
There was a group, an adult group called the council on human relations.
And they had a youth council, and they brought people from different high schools into that.
And it was a way for me to meet young people, roughly my age, all over the city,
because where I live was predominantly the African-American section on the East Side.
And again, years later, I just realized what a small portion of Cleveland.
I actually spent 99% of my time at the East Side, and maybe when we went downtown, or went to a wall game,
at the old stadium, it was on technically the West Side.
But by and large, the West Side was white people, and it was a little dangerous, and we didn't go there.
And so, again, most of my life was in this small piece of geography, called certain parts of the East Side.
And it wasn't until probably my early college years as I was coming back,
as I was beginning to realize that African-Americans were moving not so much to the West Side,
but the different parts of the East Side, which had been kind of off limits to me when I was a kid.
And Mount Pleasant area, Shaker Heights, Ludlow area, and that Shaker Heights was known
for having the first school integration in the country during that time period.
So, there were a lot of things that were going on, and the other piece was there was something called the World Council on Human Affairs,
and they had different chapters at different schools.
And different schools could, they would have a yearly mock general assembly in each school in a different country.
And I remember in the late 50s, I was at East High School, and we were France.
And so, this was during the French Algerian War, so we had to learn all the arguments back and forth,
and why France was right and why Algeria was really part of France and all that stuff.
But, again, it was like getting me into some of the broader stuff of the world, and so I looked back at it as a kind of important beginning.
And I guess one other thing I think that probably looking at the days where it was important is my dad,
I never could understand quite the principle of a labor union in terms of having to be having to force the joint.
I mean, I grew up in a democracy when person would do what you want, so why do you have to join a union?
Why do you have to be forced to join a union?
So, in 58, in both, actually, California, out here in Ohio, there was a right to work on the ballot,
and they ended up losing in both places.
And out here, that was with Mr. Nolan, was running for Senate.
No governor, he was running for governor because he wanted to be able to command the...
Just trichroica, you had...
Christopher was the...
I think...
Who was the governor?
Good one night was the governor.
And then Nolan was the senator, and of course you had Richard Nixon as the vice president, and they were all kind of big Republicans nationally.
And the question was, who was going to control the California delegation at the Democratic Party...
I mean, sorry, Republican Party convention in 1960.
And so, Nolan decided he would just...
You stripped the power and run for governor, and pushed night aside and night ended up running for Senate and losing,
and Nolan ran for governor, and he lost, but the right to work was one of the major things, as unions really,
probably one of the last times that unions really were able to flex their power and be a decisive factor in,
and they were also that in Ohio, though it got less attention than what was happening in California at the same time.
So, but my dad really convinced me, he was able to show me the important power of labor, the importance of unions,
and why crossing a union picket ride, you know, was still awful, and I still believe to this day.
So, that was all kind of parts of my beginnings and kind of getting out there.
Did he... did... is he born in 1942?
That's right.
I was born in the middle of Stalingrad.
And I guess over in Pacific, there was the fights around Midway, and so a lot of stuff was going on in the world.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
We did it in Simon. I can't remember if it was in high school or college. I think it was in college.
It was happening in the world in the year that you were born. So, it was really fascinating to go look at that,
and read what was happening in the... particularly World War II, and the struggle for Leningrad and Georgie Zuckoff and the Red Army fighting with Nazi Army in the Viermocht.
And, you know, and even... I think it was after 43, they cut off the World Series for a couple years, and baseball.
So, you saw the impact the war was having, and hey, I was a little kid. I'd be born all this time.
Did some of the major events that history textbooks would recount on US-Race relations of the mid-50s,
did those impress themselves really on US-A teenager, and thinking of, you know, brown beboors, Montgomery, Emmett Till, Little Rock?
Well, I have to a great degree with some of them did. I mean, I think it was probably the largest things that came out.
I mean, as a young man, well, young kid, I guess, teenager, when I heard about Emmett Till, I mean, that was just frightening.
And I should say, as I said, my mother is from Tennessee, and as a kid, the first six years of my life, every summer, we would go down to Tennessee.
And so, of course, when I was a little kid, I wasn't aware of where too much of what was going on.
But by the time I was about five or six, I was getting a little handle on a little small town dire right outside of not too far from Memphis,
and where we had family. And I never knew until later that riding on the train, I was riding in a segregated car,
and because usually my dad would come down and take me back, and say, we'd ride back on the train back up to Cleveland from, I guess, Memphis.
And so, I don't aware of any segregated streets or signs, and I'm sure they were there.
But we also had a black newspaper, which I think still exists, called a call and post.
And the call and post at that time was written, I mean, it was purful.
And people used to sometimes be a little bit embarrassed, so they put the call and post inside the Cleveland press,
so if they were on the bus or public transportation, they could be reading the black newspaper, but everybody wouldn't know it unless you're sitting right next to them or behind them.
But the call and post would have stuff that was happening in terms of the national black community.
As I mentioned in my kind of bio, that I was part of the Youth Council of the NAACP.
My dad was a lifetime member, though, I think he became that in the early 60s, not the actual 50s.
I mean, he was a member, but I think he became a lifetime member in the 60s.
And so we were aware, I was certainly aware of Vory Wilkins, and to a lesser degree of Walter White, who had been the leader of the NAACP before that.
But that and the urban league were the two major black organizations in Cleveland, and from being a kid to high school, in the term period.
You jumped in in, I guess, the spring of 60.
Right.
I guess that would be the reaction to the green for all they came up with that.
It was.
And so part of it was kind of being in these different circles of the Youth Council of the World Affairs, but particularly the Council on Human Relations, because we did a lot of interaction between that time African Americans and Jews,
and some degree of Catholic schools, and two lesser degree, the more white ethnics, who were from some from Appalachia, some from the Eastern European countries, the little less.
And again, looking back and realizing the class was a major factor, who I met at that time and who I didn't meet at that time, both on the white side, and in some ways on the black side as well.
Those are the only tickets of race topic, as I said.
We're back after just a quick break.
I'd like to have you just recall being an 18-year-old, I guess you would have been, or not quite 18, maybe, but nearly.
Those early tickets at Dimes' Door in Cleveland in the spring of 1960.
Well, the Dimes' Door were not officially segregated. And again, didn't think about it at the time, I'm sure at the level of employment, being able to work inside the Dimes' Door as opposed to just come and eat.
There probably was some real discrimination in segregation.
And I learned a little bit more about that when I was living years later in the 70s Detroit in terms of what was happening in the Dimes' Door in Detroit during that same time period.
I'm sure there's a very similar in Cleveland right three hours away.
But I think it was just in some ways being out on the street in this case, there was wall-warfs, there was crezghies, and a store called Nizernos.
They were all right on Euclid Avenue, and right in the heart for going from the public square to six street.
So they were all very concentrated. So we could actually hit all three of them pretty easily.
And we had signs, it wasn't that we weren't telling anybody not to go in. It was just more informational of what was happening and what these stores were doing down in the South.
And the fact that we were doing this raised a fewer within the NAACP, and our youth chapter actually got dissolved as a consequence of that.
Well, the NAACP was not quite prepared for more physical action.
I mean, they saw themselves as a bunch of lawyers. This would be an enduring thing in the 60s as well.
And in some ways, even today, they've suffered from that because a lot of illegal stuff has been officially done.
And so what's next? And they don't have a great program for that.
But then, they were very, because Cleveland saw itself as a liberal city, and a lot of the aspiring black leaders at that time were having what we would call today,
kind of sweetheart deals with some of the white power elite leaders, is to have something that was just on the streets.
And I mean, if you didn't read the science carefully, it looked like it could be a picket of a local store.
And so the fathers in NAACP said, you know, this is not the right time to be doing this.
They're better things we should be doing. I can't even think now what those better things are worth.
How did you judge those, your reaction to the disbanding of the youth chapter?
I didn't really care. I mean, which was the other part. Part of my senior year was, I mean, luckily I was halfway decent student.
But my mother was always afraid I'd have bad grades when you didn't get into good colleges. But I was many all these young kids.
And there was one grouping of folks I forgot to mention called the Circle Pines Club.
And Circle Pines was a camp in Michigan, something I had a sense of at the time it was a pinko camp.
And more recently, that's been totally confirmed. And a couple of years ago, there was the, what's it called?
There's a labor thing that happens here in the Bay Area of the Year. Labor...
I can't think of it. But about three years ago, they did this year, but about three years ago, they had something about youth camps around the country that were basically set up by the Communist Party.
Not so much per se around indoctrination, but basically around how people from different races could live together and stuff like that.
And we're playing together and learning to... parents could maybe meet each other and have lifelong connections.
So there was this young group, they were heavily Jewish, but not exclusively. And mostly white, though again, there were a few kids, black kids at that time was all white and black.
And so I joined the club because I met one of the kids at one of the high schools in Cleveland Heights.
So we spent a lot of social time together, beyond just the meetings. And so... and there was some interaction between all these youth council, the NAACP, the Circle Pines Club, human relations, and the council world affairs.
And so it'd be nice to do a little chart sometime of what that was. But the point being is that I've been getting radical ideas from some of this that was beyond even at that time the mainstream.
There was another group which was around which I kind of was aware of, but didn't get close to my mother even warned me about. Remember she's a democratic politician?
It was called the Fair Play for Cuba Group. And of course this is the time that Cuba 59 Fidel takes over.
And so...
She was just being wary of that.
Oh yeah, yeah. And this was a good time to say it. There were three things she told me not to do.
She said, Philip, don't get a girl pregnant. And that was like the future and all that.
She said, don't become a drug addict and don't become a communist.
So I said, oh, two out of three, at least. Not bad. Not bad.
But a lot of that advice was always with the thing that she was very much the mainstream.
And of course, as I said, she was in this hot seat which I totally realized at the time. And so I said, oh mom, I'm okay.
But I was getting what loosely I was reading Sea Right Mills and reading about the power elites at the time and who wasn't.
And I tried to think, well, who would that be in Cleveland or Ohio and stuff like that.
I had one very good friend at Oberlin College which was a nearby college.
And there was also a long history going back in some ways to Civil War in the ground railroad.
But in the 50s, it was, this guy had seen his liberal college.
I'm not quite sure. It must have been some conference. One of those groups I mentioned where I met a guy named Charlie Butts.
His family was Republican and he actually was back in the day where you still had liberal Republicans.
And so he was, you know, here the democratic stuff from my parents.
And then Charlie would come and talk about how they were trying to do something new.
And he eventually ran for something. And I had gone to college and so I lost track of it at a certain time.
But so there was a lot of fermentation, that's when I try to say, am I young mine?
Did you ever yourself attend Circle of Pines at Cannes?
No, never did.
What's the story of how you made the decision to at ease to Howard?
Well, that was my mother.
I had just assumed being in the high one and we were very rich.
Well, but first of all, my mother convinced me that I would never get into school.
I wanted to go to Columbia and I in New York.
And now your grades aren't going to be good enough to me too much competition.
So I applied for something local, Ohio State and Ohio University, which I got accepted to both of them.
And being a small town, Athens, Ohio didn't quite turn me on.
So I said, well, let's go to Columbus and check that out.
So I got accepted. I actually went down there, signed up.
I got a dorm room, even met my roommate who, and then my mother called me up and said, you're not going there.
You're going to Howard University.
So...
Was it the interview so late?
I'm not sure.
It was someone of a last minute thing.
Like I said, I was already had gone down to Columbus.
And the school hadn't actually started yet, but I was looking at whoever some of the courses,
the requirements, and they said, got in the room and dorm.
And she decided that she really wanted me to be in a place where there were younger, educated, black people,
part of the aspiring middle class.
She wanted me to join a fraternity and meet nice sort of sorority girls and future wife, family,
people I could network the rest of my life and felt that was more realistic.
And she probably was right, in some ways.
And another hand, which was interesting at the time, is that Howard University was actually cheaper to go to.
Then Ohio State, even being a state resident of Ohio, Howard was cheaper.
So there was a summary of the degree of the economic work.
So they essentially, my dad and mom, we drove out to Washington.
And I think as a kid, I'd gone to Niagara Falls once, but that was only another big trip I'd ever taken.
So I'm going to DC and going to the East, the nation's capital.
And then so that's how I got out to Howard University.
You were of course very quickly, that would be thickly involved in all kinds of unfolding,
civil rights activism of the early sixties.
Was that on your mind as you drove these?
Did you think that was going to be a part of your college experience?
No, didn't cross by mine.
I just wanted to see the capital and Washington Monument and the big city and just open to a new experience.
And I must admit, there are times when I thought, well, what would have happened to my life if I had stayed in Ohio?
And God, Ohio State University graduated and stayed in the state.
I mean, the civil rights movement did become a national movement.
So there would have been something where that would have touched me at some level.
And this probably given my background, I would have been interested.
I do some folks actually at Central State and in Will Beforth, who got involved.
Yeah, who got involved. And sometimes when I came back to visit in the early sixties, I'd check in with them
and just see how things were going. But it was a very different scene.
Can I take a quick break?
We're back after short break.
Mr. Herscheng, what do you want to ask?
It's interesting you were just saying that driving out to Washington DC, the civil rights, future one, that really the question is.
I mean, mind it all. Tell me about how you found your new campus life and the activities, the groups and organizations you used before long.
What did you think became involved and that was for you very quickly, and from a lot of directing, what was the golden version?
Well, Washington was a great place to be. And on different levels, one is at Howard itself, it had a friend number of foreign students.
And the foreign students were basically from three different areas. They were from the Caribbean, Trident, Jamaica, places like that.
A couple of smaller islands. And then they were from different African countries, some of them newly independent.
And the third grouping was from Iran. And I never quite understood what was the basis of them being there, not the same thing wrong with them being there.
But those were the three groups that had some degree of critical mass. There were some students from other places too.
But this was primarily African American school. A small number of white students who usually were doing like an exchange, maybe they're junior year, they come to Howard.
Because it was one of the historical black universities. But even as a kid, they think they're foreign students. I think about France and Germany.
So here I was seeing foreign students from a very, very different part of the world, and hearing it just from their mouths.
So I'm not sure there was any per se, consolidating opinion on anything that they were saying. But it was just a different than what you'd read in a Washington Post or the start.
Oh, I can't remember. There was another paper too in Washington at the time. And so that was one piece.
Two, I mean, Washington, you had this new guy, John Kennedy, who was the president. And kind of after the 50s, here you had this young man, World War II hero, in his 40s.
I was like a passing of the generations of the torch to a more, who was pushing a more activist role of government. People were coming in. A lot of intellectuals particularly, the Arthur Sylesinger's and all these folks.
It was like change was very much in the era, I guess. And so part of being in Washington was getting kind of used to this or just appreciating it. In 60 of the year I got there, of course you had the presidential election.
After the second debate, John Kennedy came to Howard University campus. He brought Jack with him. And I hope that you're all, everybody was looking at him. He went to the chapel.
And talked and we had just seen him debate Nixon. And so this was not something we were reading about in the newspaper. You know, in Ohio or some other places, this was like right here.
A little later, a few months later, I would see Richard Nixon. And at some Republican presentation, I think it was right in somewhere in Maryland, but right in suburban Washington area in Maryland.
So he had to speak. So I mean, all of a sudden the two guys were going to be running for the future presidency of the United States, part of my reality in a way that they would never have been in a different way.
So that was very part, you know, important. And then there were different events that would happen in the early 60s, the Berlin 61, most particularly the October crisis of 62,
where we were all sitting around watching the Soviet boats come toward Cuba. And where they're going to be fired on. And as Washington, the US Capitol, not like Cleveland, you know, when we be a bombed and nuked. And would this be the start of World War III and different professors weighing in on their history or experience.
So it was very much debates like what was going to happen? What should happen? Should the US do this? Should the Soviets not do that?
And so these were debates that would never happen pretty much in Cleveland. And so that was part of the milieu from the very beginning.
The other piece was just being a kind of political joiner, as I always call myself. And I joined different groups. And I got involved in the student government. I ran for office, didn't win.
But I was campaign manager for a guy who ran for the freshman class president. And then he ran for South Korea one again. So I was kind of like the little political genius behind the scenes, getting him elected and stuff like that.
Who was that? His name was Nathaniel Knight. He was from Baltimore, Maryland. And by the large again, somebody that kind of lost contact with over the years.
And tell me about, I don't understand the arc between 60 and get the fall 60 and 64 when you go to Newark.
Because you'll have, and there's a lot that happens here, none of that will action group protests, Easter arrests and 61, not a court restaurant city.
You'll go at some point to this out. You'll do a lot of work on campus to support Southern student activists. And in 64, you'll go to graduate and go to Newark.
So what company through that arc and how you were hungier with engagement with all of these questions?
Well, probably the easiest way to say this is that I come out of Cleveland interested in politics. I get involved in campus politics in the school.
Then there's this other group of folks, what's we call the NAD kids. And some of them had been to the South as early as 1960 and 61 and 61. And so they come with a different kind of experience and be on the campus.
Some of them decide, I mean, in terms of who they are, they are interested in becoming middle class black, white. They're some of them white. And they're overholes which they use in the South and the Southern struggle.
They just walk and be on campus. Very noticeable. Different buttons, one man, one vote, and all this. And so like, who are these folks? I got attracted to them.
And so eventually I would join. And if anything, that's what cuts through all the rest.
I think what I learned originally from the NAD folks is that politics should be about something. It's not just politics that, well, you're my friend. I'm going to make you president of the class student class or let's see how much money we can raise for the Catillion, the dance and swap alliances between the deltas and the amegas.
And the campus threats is that there were some bigger things that politics, getting power, getting influence, and authority should be about. And I think that probably more than anything else attracted me to these so-called NAD kids.
Most of them were, well, good majority of them, not total, were from the Northeast, New York, in some ways. And then that grouping you had people like Stokely Carmichael, who came out of the Bronx, who I met in my freshman year.
And people, yeah, Courtly Cox, of course, was there. We still call them sea cocks. And Ed Brown, who was the older brother for Rap Brown.
And the people who were part of the early freedom movement still were keeping one foot in school, at Howard, and then in the summers they'd go south. And so this was a whole new lifestyle. You do this, okay.
You don't necessarily go straight through school and get your four year to BA, but you may or may not. It was more important than what's happening in the south. That kind of scratched me.
And I always say this when I talk to people, and love us, but the thing is that Washington was the middle ground between the so-called urban north, Northeast, and the south. And in some ways geographically, and culturally, was part of the south.
But it was neutral, in some sense, that you were out of the south. And so a lot of people who were, we were meeting a lot of folks in the Senate movement who would come up to Washington to catch a breath of air, maybe raise money, do few fundraisers, maybe get a chance, run up to New York, but basically DC would be their headquarters.
And so I'd be talking to these people, and hearing what they were saying, their experiences. The ones that were most really got me were the high school students.
Because here I was in college, and I'm older, and I'm reading about government 101 and political scientists and state government that. And these are young folks who are challenging all this when they're alive.
And so, the slogan was, put your body on the line. So it was like, it's a word that some of my SDS friends came out with later, called MindFuck. And that's what it was. It just totally turned up my whole idea of what was the proper order.
And I was coming out of Cleveland and kind of aspiring black middle class, and my mother's training, I was supposed to go get a BA, meet a nice girl, get married, become a professional, get my master, maybe even doctorate, have kids, and maybe somewhere when I'm in my mid to late 30s, maybe a little no-bless oblige out there.
So maybe do something, join the NAACP, or get active in the community. But it was basically a life of preparation. And these were folks who were doing something right now. They weren't reading to get prepared.
And they were changing history, engaging that, and you're reading in the paper. The segregation laws were being challenged in Virginia, right next door, or Maryland.
And that was totally exciting. And just seemed like the right thing to be doing at the same time. I mean, why wait when the issue was right now?
I guess I would read later, Martin Luther King's great thing, why we can't wait about Birmingham, but the same kind of argument. The struggle is now we have to basically put ourselves out there.
And we may suffer consequences, but that's the risk. But that's what the risk you take for freedom. And so that really drew me into a lot of the other things.
So specifics were, we had created something, once I joined NAACP and got into this part of the group and was learning and doing it at the same time.
We were staying and having late night conversations in the dorm. And I was learning, there was one very influential person named Tom Khan.
He was white. He was a little bit older. He was from New York. He was with the League for Industrial Democracy, which clearly had a left background. His personal politics were kind of extratzkyite.
And he had been very much influenced by Max Shackman, who had been in the Communist Party and then had left and formed what was called the Shackman Tendency, which went into trot schism.
But Tom was one of the first people who had said out and talked to me about the history of the US left. And something I would never have gotten quite in the same way by reading a book about it.
And Stokely never had time to do that. He used too much action person. And we have conversation, but other kind of conversations.
Like are you coming to the M.O.? How many people can you bring? Can we get money from the student government to do this? Since food and clothing to Mississippi? Those kind of conversations.
But Project Awareness, which Tom formed, and we were all part of each other's things, brought controversial speakers to Howard campus.
The first one we brought Malcolm X. And of course the Howard University campus father, ship in their pants. And so knowing that, we tempered a little bit to have it into a debate.
And so we brought Byrd Rustin down, who was in some ways the godfather and mentor for a lot of these younger people from the New York crowd.
And it became one of my mentors also to basically debate Malcolm X. And so we got a huge turnout. And that established Project Awareness on the campus.
And then we also brought Herbert Apthacher, known communist, and the idea of having an actual real live communist. Howard University got a lot of federal money. That was what made them nervous in many ways.
And then also some of them had gone through the McCarthy period. And that's a whole other side story of how some of the brilliant minds in the political science department were writing treatises on, you know, little like how does my flower grow during the 50s because they were totally scared to lose their jobs and stuff like that.
And I mean, they could talk about in the classroom, but they couldn't really publish and put their viewpoints out and stay at Howard and feed their families and pay their rent and all that.
So you got to see some of the repercussions also taking political stands. And that was important as well.
So how about the experience of being arrested and you can stop yourself?
Let me ask you about the impact on you of the experience of being arrested, of being in demonstrations, of to shift from thinking about one set of issues in political involvement on one hand and then this action.
Change now on the other, the whole of the impacts on you of that shift in what you were doing.
Well, you know, I talk about this a lot to some of the students today and it was a dramatic impact and basically it's freedom.
My personal freedom because I became my own person. And I got arrested at a place in Baltimore, Maryland.
We worked a lot with the Congress of racial equality. It was led by a guy named Julius Hobson at the time, who somewhat of a national spokesman in court.
And given that these were, the court was mostly middle class professionals. They needed basically some soldiers who could basically afford to get arrested or even demonstrate during odd hours.
So they called up NIG in DC or they did some things in DC but one of the things we were doing was Baltimore, I mean, sorry, Maryland was officially a segregated state.
And so it was Virginia. And we would go over to Virginia, go to some of the movie theaters because Blacks either had to sit in the balcony or they could only go on certain days.
And this was like false church and Arlington and places really close to the DC. And so segregation wasn't just something you'd read about.
It was just, you know, just really right across the state line.
Maryland, we had this Saturday in the spring of 1961. And we, I got assigned with a small group of people to go to this place called the White Race Inn.
That was a Chinese restaurant. And Maryland had the state accommodations law, which they could serve whoever they wanted to. And if there was any troublemakers that basically the older or the proprietor would come out, read the site to law or read it.
And if you didn't leave in five or ten minutes, they'd call the police and you have you arrested.
So this particular day we went to the White Race Inn. We sat down, kind of, we weren't going to get served, but we just kind of were looking at the menus and having side conversations.
So it was a racially mixed group. I remember there was about, I think there were five or six of us and at least there were two white people. One was a woman, one was a guy.
And I can't remember if they were from Washington schools or from Baltimore schools. This can't remember that. And so we sat there for about maybe half hour.
And so the guy checked, he was getting nervous. And so finally he comes over and says,
he's Chinese. And says, look, I sympathize with your cause. And one time he said, I'm a colored man, too. And he actually said that.
But this is bad for business. I'm getting trouble. Could you please leave? And he said, no, we're going to sit here for a while.
And so finally he gets really desperate and he comes up and says, look, I'll make a deal with you.
I have another restaurant over in other side of town. And it's called the Brown Rice Chinese restaurant. And if you go there, I'll call ahead.
It's all on me. I'll pay for your meal, your lunch, whatever. And just go there and it'll be all over.
And we said, not today. Should have said, take a rain check though. We didn't think to say that. But we said no.
So we said it for another while. So finally he has to do the do his duty and bring out the public accommodations and read it to us.
And so he reads it to us. And we said there for about 10 minutes and saying, you should have called the police.
Well, I think we've accomplished what we set up to do here today. We've disrupted his business. He's totally freaked out on us and stuff like that.
He's not doing any real business and other people keep looking at us and wondering if there's going to be some confrontation with the police and they're nervous and some people decide not to come in and all that.
So we decided to leave. So we walk outside and we look at each other and we just said, we just messed up here.
We're supposed to get arrested or at least bring the police out. And we have just literally, I think the phrase we use at the time was we just punked out.
And probably wouldn't say that quite now, but that's what we said then. And in that I came to mind all these young high school students who I had seen and was telling you about that I admit and Howard who are younger than me who are getting arrested.
And hard on they going to look up to us when we're afraid to do stuff.
So we decided just there someone said, I think it was a young woman. She said, let's get arrested.
So we just literally sat down on the stairs in front of his restaurant. So people would have to climb in and climb out of us around this so it couldn't get in.
And of course, he freaked out the restaurant owner. So he called the police and we just we linked arms and the police couldn't pull us apart.
So they had a call another police car and then the patty wagon and then eventually they got us apart and we got us in jail.
But we got a little roughed up a little bit taking and putting us in the patty wagon. Not anything serious.
And it says what I said to them were women. We said, watch out for her. Don't have her there and all that kind of stuff.
But what I realized was that all of a sudden something was more important than going back to do my assignments at Howard for the weekend.
Something was more important than maybe a party that might be happening Saturday night. Something was more important than what my mother might think about my future or how this might fall at her career and all that.
And that's what I mean about liberation. It was real sense that all of a sudden I was making a stand. It could have been about something entirely different.
But I was making a stand from what I wanted my life to be about and while I was aware of other opinions, I was doing what I really wanted to do.
And I was willing to take whatever responsibilities in this case getting arrested for it. So in that sense it was really, it was crossing a Rubicon of sorts.
And it was very much saying this is my life. And I'm going to live it and take the consequences. And it was very much of our freeing kind of thing. That's why I met my freedom.
Let me touch on a few things and then we'll pick up the narrative again.
Does anything happen in the classroom at Howard that's really pushing you forward in these ways too? Or you had earlier said that there's kind of a disconnect there.
Was there anything, any faculty, any class that made a difference in the sense of really living in an intellectual perspective?
Not really. It's somebody that I was very disappointed with Howard.
I thought of us kind of like a 13th grade. You go through 12 grades of high school, then 13th grade. And then I guess after I read Ralph Ellison's invisible man, I said, what this looks like, it's like one of these newly developing countries in Africa.
And it felt very colonial in some sense. One because we were getting money from the federal government. The administrators were very worried about what the real powers to be were thinking and doing.
The first couple of years I was taking requirement courses, biological science, chemical stuff. And there was a political science teacher I liked. His last name was Martin. He was Robert.
And he was active in the local Democratic Party in DC. That was somewhat interesting. And as I got a little further along, there were a couple of teachers. One was very fascinating. And I didn't bring a false.
Paul was a Frenchman who had fought in the French resistance. And he also had been involved in Vietnam and Algeria. And so he brought a certain kind of sense to the courses as classes that you would get from anywhere else.
I mean, so listening to him talk, we could have been at Harvard University or anywhere. And we knew we were getting a first class thinking about this.
But by and large, the classes were at this point. I even took a course in what was then called Negro History. And it was totally boring. It was all about dates.
And well, in 1615, what happened in the Songai Empire? And no sense of context. What was happening in the bigger world? That was shaping Africa or that Africa was dealing with. Or it was like history with no politics.
And I mean, that would change particularly in the late 60s. Both in Howard and other places with black studies and the whole different focus. But I didn't get it there. And I reflect I remember in November 63 when Kennedy got killed.
We were all on the campus. And I affect that was a Negro History class. And they just told us to all come out on the campus, the whole school.
And because I wanted just to say what had happened one time. And in terms of President Kennedy. And so we were all on the campus.
But it was a boring campus. I mean, interesting people. Both some of the professors and stuff like that. But just the arrangements of being able to teach and going through the regiment was very limited.
I'm really interested in having stuff and reflect a little bit about the gender dynamics inside the movement in these years. And you were experiencing the way campus and you engage in the mathematics.
Of course.
We didn't think about gender. And that said it wasn't a big problem. I mean, I said as a man, of course, too. But women were very much around, very active. They weren't being secretaries.
And in fact, when I first joined NAG, a woman named Jeannie Bell, who I again lost contact with was one of the leaders of the local, she and Bill Mahoney were kind of a key leaders of NAG at that time period.
There were women who like Jean Wheeler from Detroit, who would go south, she would marry Frank Smith, who also went south, who later, Frank Smith would later become a DC city council person.
Ruth Howard, another person who was good friend of mine, who was very active. And some others that maybe write the second or the coming of the mind. And then because at a certain point, NAG never got recognized on Howard's campus, which we always try to get recognized.
And at a certain point, we realized this was a good thing. We were not getting recognized because once we got recognized, the other reason we got recognized is that we could have meetings on campus and we could get campus money as a student group.
And we quickly realized there are much more important things to do than either one of those two. And we'd have meetings out in people's homes, out in other campuses.
We met with kids from Georgetown, American University, George Washington, Catholic University, in a way that if we had been just a one school, whatever happened, that's why in my bio, I have about the DC students for civil rights. That's kind of came out of those connections.
And we didn't have to answer anybody in terms of what we could do, where we could meet and all this, what happened as a student group. So it became a very good thing not to get.
Yeah, let me just to mention there's a child who would go down to the Tennessee.
But what I did do is I did go back to Tennessee because it was one of the summers. I want to say, yeah, it had to be 62 because 63 I was doing my channel watching and stuff.
But I wanted to see as a young man, stuff I had seen or missing as a young kid. And there was a little bit of movement, not a big movement in Memphis at the time. And particularly not in a smaller town.
I was my cousins. And so that was the official reason to go and see cousins and I had kind of a big older cousin, I always call her big sister. She's still alive, 10 years older than me. She lives in St. Louis now. But she saw as a house in dire Tennessee.
So I just go around and all of a sudden I did see the segregation signs. I did see white people, somehow I must have seen as a young kid that didn't really dawn on me because it was pretty much like a black world, world that I was kind of in as a young kid.
And then I saw some of the reaction where some of the folks were trying to do something around somewhere, right? And the voter registration and the harassment they were getting.
So that was, I mean, just as like revisiting my past, but in a different way.
I'd love to have you describe your experience in the SIPIAN64 because you helped with the MFPP efforts. That of course concludes that sort of has that great debacle of the climax in Atlanta City.
Well, going to the MFPPAN64 was, I went slightly limited in terms of I was working on something very particular. So there were friends I knew from NG who had gone as I mentioned in the summers.
And so I went to a couple of projects mostly in the second Congressional District. One of them was Ruleville where Mrs. Hammer was, Fannie Lou Hammer was.
And I do a lot of the staff people. Stokely was doing stuff. And Ivan Hodonelsson was around. Some other people I'm not thinking about at the moment.
And so, but my focus was to try to work with the end of the Mrs. SIPI Freedom Democratic Party with the focus on the challenge that was coming up in later that year.
And what we wanted to do, because nobody trusted state officials, is we wanted to get the records of people who registered the vote and basically get their signatures, make duplicates, and then take them out of the state.
And so I was kind of in and out going to different projects, but sitting in a lot of meetings. And also particularly with the people going out to see people who were doing voter registration. But really being in the community meetings.
I mean, I probably the thing that I think about that I value the most was seeing people making attempts to do democracy at the very most grassroots level. And also the other piece which was probably in the long run even more important, like when I compare them, is people being able to have complicated discussions with basic language with people who hadn't gotten through probably even high school.
And so, but how do you do that kind of conversation without dumbing it down? And that was, and you can only do that from the standpoint of organizing and developing relationships, because part of it was learning how people use language.
And so you couldn't just come down and talk or even, because then you say, oh, these poor people, they only have six grade or less education. So I have to talk in one syllable words.
And that's the wrong approach. The only one that somebody could just coming in for a quick visit naturally with no I think. So our approach was from organizers who had been there, at least all summer, maybe several summers. Some people just decided to be there and dropped out of school.
And the work on this is that you were able to know how people thought of their thinking patterns, how they approached ideas, what was the language they used around those ideas. And then how to, so in that language, wasn't so much like a foreign language, but it was kind of dialect at some level, is to basically talk about
the addressing devote state government, and particularly a restrictive state government. And what were some options around strategy in a ways that appeal to them and where they could participate. And I think, you know, that's probably the greatest lesson I learned.
And you know, watching Mrs. Hamer, you know, just talk to people, sometimes break out into a song. And the song would be not just a song, it would be a reflection of the boot in the room. And therefore the words would pick up on what people were thinking about, feeling about, maybe wanting to do, maybe scared, whatever. But maybe you couldn't just say that in a conversation.
So you had to take a song to do that and sing the power of how that cultural manifestation is able to be used in a very political way. That was the profound learning.
I've been asked, and just not incidentally I think, you had come up in the church and believed by that, I guess, what were you, will you have set up yourself at the time that you were a person of faith? Is that a part of the culture?
No, no, no, I wouldn't tell you at all. I thought church was pretty boring too. I like Sunday school because it was about history. Now the Philistines and the Israelites and the Romans and all that, but I could, yeah, so I could follow that. But I never really felt that God was in our church.
It was a nice church, middle class church is still there, and it's in the University Heights Circle Brother in Cleveland. But it ain't got supposed to be everywhere.
So why do I have to go to that church at 11 o'clock in the Sunday morning to be in God's presence when I could do that at home or be with some friends or we could have a meeting on the park and do the same kind of thing, but why this church business?
Did you find yourself in a place where you had to be because you were in the circus and was fearful, actively fearful for you?
Oh yeah. What are the things actually that we're doing right now, relatively speaking? Is the berry of veterans of the Civil Rights Movement?
We're actually doing, we take records and discussions of dead and now and all that, and one of the ones we're doing is around fear in the movement.
And I mean, it's impossible. I mean, Mississippi, I mean, need us some own, set it, you know. Alabama's bad, Georgia's awful, but Mississippi, God damn. And it was like the worst.
And you were literally going into a battleground and the only comparison that I've been able to get in terms of conversation or listening, because I never went to Vietnam.
I went to the whole another story, but it's talking to people who were in Vietnam and just the fact that they were in a pressure cooker. There was no way to get out of it.
And it's anything could happen at any moment. And that's the closest I felt in terms of the Mississippi experience. And then I didn't stay there that long, but talk to people, my friend who's here now, a guy named Wazir Peacock, Willy Peacock, who's from Mississippi and talked about being a Civil Rights activist in that kind of pressure cooker or people like Hollis Watkins who's still down there with group called Mississippi Echo even now today.
It's like, this is a war zone. And you can get killed anytime. Sniper could get you just like in Vietnam or it could be straight out of salt.
We had to know how to talk to the state officials who would come out after you and tell you to get out of town. And yet you had to stay there, but also not directly confront them.
And so they had to do something to get out of town and I went on one, because they had the guns, they had the law, they had everything. And they had to FBI watching, but doing nothing.
So yeah, it was literally a pressure curve.
I mean, that's why to something where we lived together in project houses, part of it was
that if I was living by myself, I'd be totally freaked out.
And I guess about my whole time in the movement, I publicly say as a way to get people thinking
is that 90% of the stuff I did there in the movement I probably would never have done
on my own.
And I could only even just think about it and sum it up the courage to do some of this
if there were other people who were involved with me and we were doing it together.
And so I say that to younger people today and even some adults as a way to think about
you don't have to do this all by yourself.
And part of the power of being able to fork for social change is that you have people
in some institutions, not a whole lot.
And the South, the church was very important when it was kind of a sanctuary.
But you know, that really gave us some degree of backbone.
So with times when people were in jail, they'd sing and drive the jailers crazy.
So they would be glad to give us out of there because that's not making so much noise.
But it's like I couldn't see you, but I could hear you sing in.
And so Paul and Silas, bound in jail, then you'd do the next verse.
So we were creating community right in the jail.
And so I mean that felt that fear though.
That's what it was about.
It was about just singing.
That was about fighting fear.
I remember getting tear gas in Cambridge, Maryland.
And what was that?
64.
George Wallace came to town.
Cambridge, Maryland, Eastern, Shore, Maryland.
I guess he was running for president.
That was tough fighting in Cambridge.
Yeah, and so we were off there marching on the front lines and you saw the National Guard.
And they were pointing these turned out to be tear gas canisters at us.
And we couldn't stop marching.
So we started saying, we are not afraid.
And keep marching.
And of course we got tear gas.
But again, we clutched and helped each other.
The guy named Ritchie Robinson, who was in SNCC and he's now in DC.
And we were right together and we fell together and we kind of staggered out of the crowd
and back to safety that night.
And Rat Brown was there and he got arrested, or re-arrested, probably more accurately.
And I remember I went back to Howard University in my fatigues and tear gas.
I went straight to my ROTC class and deliberately went to smell up the whole place.
Okay, Hutchings, where have you been?
We were in ROTC.
Yeah, he had to be, it was a mandatory.
For two years, yeah.
Did Atlantic City, was it a point of transition for you or a point of continuity?
Well, it was kind of newly insensitive to another part of the struggle.
But just given what happened there and that the MFDP did not get seated and people left,
there was a real depression that settled on the movement.
And you know, I think that right away, I mean, I was sorry that we didn't admit that
practical politician part of me is like, if we only had done this or this or this, of
course, but we were dealing with Lyndon Johnson.
And so probably in the long run wasn't possible.
And so I think it sank in at a later time.
And I remember when my mother died, much later, in 1991, as I went out to Cleveland and
went to the funeral, I'm only a child, did all this stuff.
And then I took care of the burial, met with the minister, all that.
Good soldier came back to California.
And I was doing consulting at the time, so I had to get my back on stuff.
And all of a sudden, my body just closed down on me.
It's like say, okay, you want to do all that stuff?
I'm not moving.
And for like two weeks, I just sat in the house and basically mourned my mom.
And I think something not quite as dramatic, but something very similar happened in the
same way.
It was a little delayed reaction that's what I'm going to say.
And it was like, literally, what to do next.
And as you saw from my bio, I went back to North and where some friends I had from again
from the NAG days, and ended up working for Robert Kennedy.
And in a very interesting position as a research, research in Speaker's Bureau, because he was
running against a liberal liberal republican kind of kidding.
And somehow beyond the hype of being a Kennedy, you had to kind of say, well, what's the
difference between being a liberal republican and a liberal democrat?
And so that's the research part that came in very useful in being able to do that.
And of course, the speaking part was to go out and basically speak.
And all of the people around at that time, I mean, I was feeling that Kennedy was probably
Robert, even though we used to call them all kind of names when we couldn't get any
trekkles assistance down in the Cecippi or the South, is that he at least understood what
that experience was.
And he was growing as you know, later things, and that he could become more than he was
at the time.
And nobody else quite seemed to have that.
And so being a Kennedy, he would make a major mark on the Democratic Party and maybe
the country.
And so that was kind of my rationale for working in that campaign.
But it was also, it got me out of Mississippi, it got me out of that funk and basically put
me in a different situation.
How did you find your way to Newark?
Well, that's, it's fairly immediate because I went to Newark in December of 1964 and
the election for Kennedy was November of 1964, of course, right across the river.
But this has to do another little piece.
I guess I think I'm one of a few people in the movement who was both an SDS and a stick
at the same time.
I had this really crazy idea, which didn't really work out.
It was interesting is that a stick was mostly active as organization.
So somehow I would do my action and a stick.
And then I, SNCCS did a lot of these working papers on state and society, America and the
New Era.
What was the meaning of corporate liberalism?
All of that interesting stuff.
Guy named Richard Flax, who's hit down in Southern California now.
It was one of the key people, Tom Hayden.
And back in 1964, early 1964, I got up to Ann Arbor, Michigan for a conference that they
were putting on.
And I got to meet a lot of these people.
One of my good friends, who was part of the old Circle Pines group in Cleveland, named
David Strauss, was a student at the University of Michigan.
And he was also very active in the voice chapter, the student group, SDS political party at
UBM.
So through him, I got to meet people like Tom Hayden and Al Haber, who were the former
of SDS.
So I said that's where that piece started.
And then I got to know some of the SDS people in DC.
It weren't that many, mostly around George Washington University.
And they mostly were in the peace movement.
And at the time, and some of them individually, they had done certain things in the civil
rights movement, particularly some of them had gone north to Chester, Pennsylvania right
outside of Philadelphia and been active in community work there.
But anyway, SDS had started these economic research and action project to actually do
work in the field.
And the model was sick.
And they were going to try to do what they call the interracial movement of the poor.
And places in Chicago, Cleveland, Boston, and I'm probably missing someplace.
Yeah, Baltimore joined in Baltimore.
And so I went to a party and ran to Tom Hayden.
And he's got the talking.
I always say he got me drunk.
And so he said, when did you come out of the door?
See what we're doing.
It's a lot like SNCC.
And hey, you know, you're from the north.
You probably can help us out on some stuff.
So probably with the liquor and still in this post-Atlantic City thing.
And I knew I was going to do the thing with Kennedy.
I mean, he became a senator and that was good at the time.
But I had no dreams of wanting to go to Washington and do that.
So I said, let's go to check out Newark.
And it was appealing because they, at the time, are talking about a statewide movement.
And the idea that in terms of the 60 census, New Jersey was at that time the most, I don't
know it, still maybe, but that was the most urbanized state in the country.
So the idea was to start at Newark and Hoboken.
And they had a project at Hoboken when at Newark.
And we talked about doing something in the Elizabeth.
And then maybe working down to Trenton.
And there were some university people at New Brunswick and also at Princeton that, in terms
of the academic level and research would be helpful.
And so it was like a statewide movement.
It wasn't just like going to one city, even though you were technically in one city.
But the idea was going to there.
And so that was appealing.
And then the Jersey Turnpike, you can just connect really easily from city to city,
place to place, which you couldn't do in Mississippi so easily.
So that was attractive.
And so I'd always wanted to be in the North and do stuff.
I had this little quote that the success of the anti-Jim Crow would be to turn Birmingham
into Chicago.
And places like Atlanta would become like New York.
And so we would be facing the real problems of this country in a way that segregation,
racial segregation, had not allowed it to happen.
And so this great victories that we were getting and which were hard fought and well earned
and well deserved, were basically just putting us into the situation where we were like
everybody else.
And what's the America in that greater country economically, politically, and for freedom?
And so that had always been my focus about why you had to work in the North.
And so Newark opened that possibility.
And SDS had a project and they actually, most of their organizers were white.
They had a couple of black organizers.
That was the part of it.
I did not get to claim false labeling.
I mean, we got there.
There was no interracial movement of the poor.
There were no white people who wanted to work with us.
We were Stanley Oranoids and other people.
I did all these surveys on unemployment and particularly focused on New Jersey.
And that was, and we thought we were going to work around unemployment.
Well, that was not the issue people wanted to work on.
They wanted to work around housing and rent and police brutality and things like that,
which is what, you know, you do what the folks want to do.
You're organizing it or you don't have a real project.
So we ended up doing that.
And it was mostly, you know, a black community.
And we broke with the kind of more liberal group, the Clinton Hill neighborhood association.
Got to name Stanley Winters, was head of that.
And they had a very limited, kind of very, just generally at the time liberal.
And we wanted to do more than that and raise basic questions.
And so we broke off in the local, what was called the lower, hit the Clinton Hill section.
And became a real power base.
And then eventually, a year later, we'd start doing stuff in the central ward of New
work, which was even more black and more poor and kind of the cesspool of New work.
And I remember being with Tom Hayden in 65 during the Watts rebellion.
And we were sitting there talking, looking at TV and saying, what is this is going to
happen in New Jersey, in Newark.
And more importantly, what would that impact be on us, what should we be doing, and so
on.
And so we, out of that conversation, then bringing other people into it, we developed
a strategy for the next what became, we didn't know when, the next two years, so that when
the Newark rebellion actually happened, you know, we had a game plan and an organizing
thing of how to work on this.
And it was basically as the move, but this was going into the mid 60s, becoming more racial
conscious and the more black focus is we end to put issues in more racial terms.
And since Newark was predominantly black at that time, still is today, and the people
who were poor in destitute were also poor blacks.
But the power structure, in this case, unlike Cleveland, which was Irish, were Italians.
And as we began to pose that, like Newark was kind of many, this was one of the third
role concepts we're heavy and people.
So we were like a colonial African nation, struggling against these white European, Italian,
American colonialists to get our liberation.
I mean, quite say it that way, but that was the general thought.
And so, as I mentioned in the bio, we were talking about black institutions and black
power, community control, schools, neighborhoods, et cetera.
We would get more black policemen.
And I remember going through, you know, and this is what sort of, some of the class stuff
gets in the involves too, because, well, why are you arguing for black policemen?
And because police arrest people, they're agents of the state.
And our answer was, which wasn't true in Mississippi, too, was, well, people have never seen
black policemen.
And until they actually see a black policeman, get up, get beat up by a black policeman,
they won't get to see what police are really about.
They're going to think it's really a white control thing.
And so they have to get at the level through direct experience of seeing the system at
work using black people.
But if there are no black people at the higher ranks of the city of the system, which
includes mayors and congresspeople as well, then I mean, this is where we get some of
our left friends who just way out and left feel literally is that you can't talk about socialism
or capitalism at a level when people are feeling the racial thing, you know, most heavy in
their daily life.
So I mean, that became some of the things.
So we spent a lot of time polarizing.
And what's interesting in terms of new experience for me looking back on it is we were, you know,
we had some real power.
I mean, the authorities really had, look, because we had a real grassroots base.
And nothing I've worked with in the same way since has had that type of grassroots base,
where the mayor and the city council, you know, were very, you know, concerned and leery
what we were going to do, tried to bring in some of the old, but we called them, the uncle
thoms who were the Negro politicians.
And I mean, they literally broke our windows and slashed some of the tires of the people
on the car.
And one time we were in the middle of Springfield Lab, then we almost got a physical
altercation with them.
And I forget how that stopped, but it didn't actually happen.
And the guy who was hit at the local Democratic Party and the central ward got him, Ulyss
Honey Ward.
Very good guy, but he was totally into the old framework.
And he wasn't knock our blocks off because we were these new folks and all these white
radicals from SDS, it really set us up to do this.
And blah, blah, blah.
I mean, you probably heard variations in the story.
So it was very thrilling, you've disailyced.
And we lived in the community.
I stayed.
We didn't have a project house at one time.
We got a little bit more money.
We got most of our money from Weber unions.
And probably, I know the UWA gave us some money.
There was another union, which I can't remember that would give us some money.
And some church money, mostly from the Episcopal Pallion Church, which is how I got in contact
with Nathan Wright.
And he would write a book on Black Power and Newark, but more importantly, he was the
organizer for the first Black Power Conference right after the Newark Rebellion.
And he didn't have that grass roots thing.
That's how that was my role to come in and do that.
But he had other kinds of ties, which I didn't have.
And so that was useful.
Let me ask how you're bridging between SDS and Central Ward, which isn't basically entirely
black.
How are you managing between pre-managing the race and class question simultaneously,
organizational sense?
Well, in terms of what we call NCOP, Newark Community Union Project, which was an SDS-oriented
organized project, is that pretty much entirely organized by SDS.
Most of their work was pretty much all their work, except with them, has been in the South
Ward, except with some of the little forerays that mostly Tom had done, Tom Hayden, had
done an essential award.
And we'd done that together.
But at a certain point by 65, I think some of the white folks were realizing the limitations
of white organizing in a predominantly black community in a way that had not really been
raised quite as heavily in the early 60s, or even when the project first started.
And since the idea of the interracial movement of the port was not happening, it wasn't
like they could go to white folks and offer the hand of unity and bridging the gap and all
of that.
So some of them began to play more technical roles, fundraising, doing research on city
structures, which was totally useful, because frontline organizers never have time in any
struggle to do that kind of stuff.
Working ties with some of the university people, but playing of that's a visible role.
They also got race-baited.
I mean, Leroy Jones, who was his home base for where he'd grown up, and he had formed
his group called the Spirit House, actually got a race-baited, not kind of he did.
And I know sometimes the meetings he would ask me, well, who are you representing these
white folks, or are you representing, are you with us?
And I said, we say, I'm representing people that I'm organizing in the Central Ward, who
were like 99% black.
And also we got allies.
One guy was a guy named Willie Wright, who became, oh, she'd say, one of the things that
happened in somewhere, I guess, between 64 and 64 is this thing called the poverty program,
anti-apomany program.
And because there was a national program everywhere and had money and resources, we had to figure
out how to do with it.
Yeah, so we had to figure out whether we should ignore it and some of the things like the
VISTA program, which would bring in young, predominantly white kids into some of the same
areas that we were working in, or should we try to take it over.
So after some major discussions, we had a similar debate on this around the Democratic
Party, by the way.
There was something called the United Freedom Party, which is like a third party was led
by a guy named George Richardson, who had been a former state assemblyman with a Democrat,
and had broken with the Democratic boss.
And as a way to threaten him, the boss, that is, he formed the third line so that the
Republicans could seevably win if they withheld a significant vote.
So that was a prior discussion that had gotten us thinking about that kind of strategy.
But we decided not to do that in the case of the federal government, and we decided
that's what we have a community base.
Let's become the poverty program, because the feds can't do that.
So we basically, what was called District 3, which is a South Ward, we literally had
the forces to take over the poverty.
We hired one of our own people as the staff organizer, got named Jesse Allen, and Bessie
Smith, who was our version of Fannie Lou Hamer, was the chairperson, not paid, Jesse was
paid of the board.
We had quarters where the government office at that poverty program in the third ward.
In the central ward, we didn't quite have, we hadn't spent as much time developing
base.
So we had some base, and we were able to work with a guy who was kind of like a local black
nationalist, and they didn't really write.
And he almost, when he gave speeches, he kind of reminded you of Malcolm X a little bit.
But, you know, we were, what tied us together, we were both insurgent forces.
So we got him elected to be the chairman of the area board too.
So we essentially controlled two boards in the two most poverty-stricken areas of Newark.
And so we were a serious force, you know, to be dealt with.
So there were some downsides, I mean, and to that, what is that?
In the focus of the government, in the government large, yes, we lost a little bit of the community.
Not so much in terms of actual people, but being able to have that, I mean, before the
government, we spent like 90% of our time in the community on the day, and during the
day.
In fact, the folks of these nonprofits now who go out and I even belong to a couple,
it's a big thing for them to go out to their community once a week and for a couple
of hours.
And we were there six days a week and more frequent on the weekends, I'd take advantage
of the closest of New York and take the subway, the path over to spend time in New York,
saying, hang, get out of it for a minute and come back.
But we were there.
But we lost that because what happened is that we had these fancy phones with push buttons
and Jesse, who was the organizer and Dolvin Higgins, who was another sub organizer.
They could just spend all their time in their office and didn't have to go out in the
community and knock on doors anymore.
It's like, you come to us and we had these nice couches, leather couches that were said,
where before people had donated their own couches to our neighborhood storefront office.
So there was a sense of ownership at the community level that they had.
They had put up money or they had put up their furniture.
We had meals together, which we had paid for and we shared.
And we were poor, but we shared and we made do.
All of a sudden now we have nice big meeting halls and phones and come down to my office.
I don't have time to talk to five different people.
I don't have time to do that.
I'm saying the most provocative way.
It wasn't quite felt that way all the time.
But that's why I say we lost a little bit of the community or the community feel of
in the poverty program.
But for 64, you know, that little famous clause, the maximum feasible possession of the
poor, we worked it to the bone.
And in fact, one time a new director of the, it was called the United Community Corporation.
You see that was the official name of the poverty program in Newark.
They had a new director come in from the urban league and he would later come to Cleveland.
That's kind of interesting.
But the community wanted to have some buttons.
So they wanted to have their community action director.
And so they nominated me to be the community action director.
And of course, the top folks didn't want that.
So I didn't get the position.
And I remember looking at it in hindsight, there was a salary of $12,000, which was big time
money.
I never got $12,000 in my life.
So a small part, I was like, hey, I wouldn't become rich in this job.
And because we were kind of living hand to foot at the level of, that's my joke by the way
now.
I can tell you politically how I got through the 60s.
But if you had to ask me economically how I managed to get through the 60s, I could be
down in Guantanamo and being tortured.
And I could not give you a yearly account or a monthly account for all those years of
how I survived.
You'd have to torture me and I couldn't do it.
Because having, that's, I mean, it was a whole different climate.
Sharing, sleeping on people's sofas and community folks letting us stay in the house.
I used to have this very elaborate system of where I was getting meals.
And so I'd say, okay, Joe, I actually went down.
So the first Monday and the third Tuesday of each month, I'm going to come over your
house.
I'm just going to happen to drop by at dinner time.
And because you saw me in the community, you say, hey, I'm full.
Stay for dinner.
Okay.
You, I'm going to come all the third Wednesday and the fifth month of the month.
And I do my whole couple of blocks that I was kind of liaison for.
So it would look spontaneous.
But it would be very planned and I would know I'd have meals.
Because I'd bring news.
And so I was always, it's like that famous commercial I was used to love about the guy
who goes camping and all he takes to the six pack of blood wiser.
And everybody comes and greets them and takes them and takes good care of them.
I mean, I brought the news.
I could tell you what your neighbor was doing, what the landlord was doing, what the
electric company was, who was fussing with that or the church meeting here.
And so I was in some ways a welcome guest.
I mean, he was partly organizing.
And I could be part of the social thing.
I was telling somebody here that what, as part of the Explore, one of the central ward neighborhoods,
I went into this bar and they said, I was looking to see what was happening and going
on and I was new.
And so I saw something on the bar and said, Christian bothers meet from two to three every Sunday.
I said, oh, that's a good, I'm going to check out with.
And so I asked him, and Barthand I said, what does this Christian brothers group do in
their meetings?
And he got to be kind of the way you, you're just looking at that.
Oh, we just drink Christian brothers liquor.
Here I said it was going to be a social group and make connections.
So I had a lot of great stories like that.
And that's what made it interesting and learning at the same time.
And you felt you were in the public.
Yeah.
I mean, I said we had a face in the city.
And so I mean, after the rebellion, folks wanted to blame the riot on us and to say the
agree.
Yeah, before we get to that, would the mayor of Newark have known who you are in this
year?
I don't know.
Some of his people would have.
He had a guy named Donald Melafronte, who I can't remember his exact title, but he was
like chief of staff.
And I decided, because he was at every community meeting running down the garbage from the mayor's
office.
So I personally decided to make him the arch bad guy.
And so anytime I had a chance, publicly or privately, I actually would have called him.
There was a guy named White Guy, an interesting guy who's dead, unfortunately, named Derek
Wyden's.
He came from a fairly wealthy family in New Jersey.
I can't remember exactly what their money was from.
But Derek got interested in the movement.
And since hometown, he saw us and some of the people we were close to being the real
progressive force of the future.
And so he did all kinds of things to help us.
So one of the things he did, he said a newspaper, a community newspaper called The Newark
Advance.
And I wrote a column.
And I think I came out every two weeks or something like that.
And so usually I find somebody in the column that talk about Donald Melafronte and as the
arch bad guy of everything.
And so he would know who I was.
And then some of the really good guy named Doug Edwards, who wrote for the Newark Star
Ledger.
And he covered a lot of our stuff.
And I don't know if he's still alive or if he's passed out.
So we were picking our friends on enemies mainly because we were a force beyond the neighborhood.
If we were just in the neighborhood, folks downtown wouldn't have cared that much.
But because we had a much bigger view, we were making ties, connections on the West Ward,
which by 67 we had really kind of real basin.
But I mean people were aware of us as a force in the town.
And that's why I say I've never been anything quite like that since.
Whether Detroit or here where he had that access to some degree of cloud.
How are you managing say 65, 66 with?
Would you formally describe yourself still then after you're sort of deeply in the Newark
experience as a member of SNCC?
Well no.
I mean some of it's personality, some of it's politics, some it's cross.
It's really the energy that's happening with the times.
So like I moved to December, Newark in December thanks to Tom Hayden and the party and all
that.
And was bringing in the work with in cup again doing community work.
And all of a sudden SDS decided that they wanted to do this March in Washington.
It would become the first major march against the war in Vietnam.
In April, I think I want to say 19th, 1965.
I think.
But anyway, in April, 1965 Paul Booth was the national chair of SDS the time was the main
speaker and his great speech was we have to name the system.
You know, just that protest.
But anyway, but the problem is SDS didn't have any real basin DC.
And so I remember they came up to Newark and asked if I could be released to go back to
Washington where I got new people and be one of the organizers for the March.
And which I said to the SDS people, I mean to the Iraq people in cup, you know, it was
up to them.
And they said, yeah, this is important because there's a big work we're doing in Newark.
We think it's important, but there's also a world which we have to have an awareness of.
And if you have some skills in DC and can do some of this, so the lead organizer from
SDS was a guy named Paul Booth, who I think at the time was the national vice president.
And he was there and I was the main organizer.
And in some ways I had done something a little different, but similar in 63 with the March
and Washington committee.
And you had Byred Rustin, who again was one of our mentors, who was basically organizing
the National March and Washington somewhere along the line, they realized they had forgotten
about DC.
And we're bringing all these people from all over the country and nobody has tried to do
anything about mobilizing Washington DC, the people there.
And they're going to feel totally invaded.
And what is this and all that.
So he leaned on some of the NAD kids as we were called and to actually do some, so we
formed a little group and he said we will basically be the organizers for Gideon Cleveland
Robinson, who was one of the more national folks in the March and Washington gave us money,
oh, she'd say, God, us money didn't give it to us personally, I was pocket.
But you got some money to set up an office.
And then later a couple of deaths in the main office so we could have coronation and
Norman Hill from court, Congress, racial equality was part of that.
I say him because he was our generation.
He was one of the younger upcoming people in court at that time.
And we basically organized in DC.
Cleveland Robinson went to the unions in DC.
We went to a lot of churches, community groups, so that we could get a turnout.
But also people, we got places for people to stay, who were coming not just for the day
from other places.
Churches opened up so people could go and get food and clothing.
Not so much clothing, but food and water and respite, missments for a while.
So again it was just having gone to college and done some work in DC that made that possible
in 63 and then also in 65 now with the anti-war thing.
Then after that I went right back to Newark.
Yeah.
So in terms of the SDS stick thing, I think some of the SDS people were moving more consciously
to the anti-Vietnam War thing in real, in some degree in relationship to the more black,
nationalist tone around organizing in urban communities.
It wasn't necessarily a boom, boom thing.
It was gradual and some people stayed like Tom stayed for a long time.
But then Tom went to Vietnam with Herbert Abducker and Staten Linh.
Then he came back to Newark and talked about what it was like to be in Vietnam and he
was able to humanize both Vietnam and the Vietnamese in a way that never would have been possible
if somebody had that we knew, you know, had gone to Vietnam.
But that was that shift.
And so what happened with me personally is this goes back to Nag, is that when Stokley
becomes chair of SNCC and wants to take you in a different direction, I remember he
comes up to Newark, we talk and he says you want to be part of this new action.
And I said this sounds cool.
And at the time also it allowed me to think about a different kind of focus for the
Central Ward which was more around the black power as opposed to just the black and white
thing.
And which in terms of people's real life experience they didn't see that happening.
So it was a theoretical construct.
Let me get you right at that moment and say when Stokley comes to have this conversation
with you, he's the spring of 1966 I guess when he asked John Lewis that.
John still says a matter about that too.
Tell me about how you would have, in some basic summary fashion, you describe the vision
of the perspective you had, the way you added up what you were trying to do and what
your critique was and how you wanted to get where you wanted to go.
In Newarker in general?
In general.
Your philosophy about how to do what you wanted to do.
Well I think coming up both starting with SNCC and then the experience in Newark with
SDS is we felt that the true bearers of future change were going to be the grassroots
communities, poor people, even poor white people that we were running into and organizing
in certain places.
And so we were afforded in some ways doing the prototype of what would be the future
society.
There were going to be room for a lot of allies and the church, the labor unions, research
and teachers so.
But in terms of where the force of that change was going to come from, was people who had
gotten the least and had the least stake in maintaining the current setup of the way
government and the society was set up.
So we felt that what SNCC was doing and what SDS was doing emphasized that and that as
the racial dynamic as was getting to spread around the country, thanks to the urban rebellions
all around the country.
And we were experiencing something which we had no real answer for in terms of our southern
experience.
And I was true with Martin Luther King with the Chicago, he did the same thing happen.
Both at the level of the violence but also at the level of the Democratic Party because
our whole objective in the South had been to get into something that was keeping us out.
So when Martin King gets to Chicago, Mary daily says come on in, become a Democrat and
join the party.
Of course you're going to be at the bottom and I mean your key authorities, well the
first is all we'll make a symbolic position for you but everybody else is going to come
in at the bottom level and we'll just replay the society with new forms now.
And the civil rights movement, the traditional southern base civil rights movement had no
answer for that either.
So both at the level of the increasing violence, people not feeling a inherent to nonviolence
as well as the fact that there was racism without segregation laws in the North, we didn't
have an answer to that.
So it was like we had to make up as we went along because there was no theoretical
struggles for how that was going to happen.
Would you see the elements that were essentially reformists and the elements were radical?
Which?
How would you have said in my program, these are essentially reformists and these are
essentially radical?
Well for the most part we were against the Democratic Party and because we felt the Democratic
Party was sometimes people said the plantation which caught up and trapped all the, particularly
that time, the black initiative that was trying to rise up and that in some ways it might
be better than the sharecropper system of the South but it was still a bondied system
and that the way people called the, whether it was Tamini Hall in New York or the Daily
Machine in Chicago and variations of that around the country, they still made the rules.
I mean it was the Democratic Party machine in Newark, the Italians and Irish as second
classes and then we were at the very bottom and then there were few blacks who got into
that was bottom level position but they were bottom level positions and most of us didn't
get into it at all so that was not benefiting anybody that we were trying to organize and
that we had to give people some sense that civic action in the old sense of that word,
civic action could make a difference and it was not going to be through mainstream structures.
I mean what about how you saw what your program was to sort of overleak that obstacle posed
by the Democratic Party by that structural reality? Well as I said we went through again learning
as we did so like in Newark, remember we made this temporary alliance with George Richardson,
the former state's assemblyman to work in something called the United Freedom Party,
UFP, United Freedom Party and that was experience, I mean it was a little bit beyond our scope
because we were the involved, we were door knockers and people's issues around housing and welfare
and not electoral politics because electoral politics was basically a field that was way beyond
our control to and pretty much bringing me a group to actually control that and not just at
a level of money but money being an important one as well and we were coming abreast at the time
on television which it really got in terms of the early 60s but by the mid 60s people were
saying things which are never were possible to do and having access to those things. I mean we
were fortunate but in terms of the day that particularly in the black power period at any time
we used to joke, you just put up here dark glasses and love a jacket and say boo and you're on page
one, you especially have a big afro and that's no longer true for us, press learns too but sometimes
you would use the other side or some of the apparatus on the other side to promote your cause
and so that became one of the things that happened stick a little later which was unfortunate is
that we frequently talk essentially what we used to call the white press to make announcements to
black people would be us we didn't have our own institutions to be able to do that, you know
it was a real problem that I mean it worked and it didn't work because then the press could do
the interpretation they would carry us but then so frequently and this it was true particularly
with Stokeley he would always say I miss being miss quoted and or be quoted out of context
because that was they would carry him in the you know he'd be on front page or whatever
but usually in a way that showed him as a wild man making all these volatile statements
and no sense of you know context for that. When you took a remarkable came to in 66 with this
proposal that you were mentioning but were you because of your history and time together back in
nag and Howard would you have said you were you had a personal friendship that you were moving
forward from or an alliance born of common struggle you know or different roles in the common
struggle. Well some of both I mean I knew his family I know the mother I actually had a brief
flirtation with his sister and visited his house in the Bronx and so I mean we weren't necessarily
I wouldn't say that he was my best friend and I don't think he would ever say I was his best friend
and we we challenged each other a lot of things I looked up to him totally but there were things I
mean I was not comfortable with him on certain politically that is on certain things but at the
level of public stance you know I loved him and you guys see he just represented like some people
say that Malcolm does or he did better. A sense of a black particularly black manhood asserting
itself in a way that was not convenient or comfortable for the white mainstream society.
Take me forward from your conversation with Carmichael in 66 through well of course we're
gonna we're gonna encounter the New York rebellion in the summer of 77. 67. Excuse me, 67th
of course and Carmichael departs Nick in 67 and then your brown will come in. Yeah kind of
talking through that that's a lot to talk about. Well one thing I did in in 66 as part of that
interchange is Stokely one of people who he knew to travel with him so I went on several trips with
him I mean he was speaking for what was that time was making money a thousand dollars of
speaking gauge which Nick badly needed. Everybody went up to to Seattle Washington to the university
there and I remember going to with Charles Lloyd concert just a matter of record kind of Charles
Lloyd. We went up to Bard College in New York State and then I went to the university with
him with him in in journalism Milwaukee or Madison I think it was yeah no that's right I'm
tempted to say Milwaukee because I remember there was this Locust Street that seemed to be everywhere
it was the main street. Everywhere we always came back on Locust and I think that I think I
think I was in Milwaukee but in the process of flying out and talking we'd have a lot of conversation
on the plane and and then after whatever the activity days event we'd kind of debrief
and with the bar trip cleave sellers went up with us and then Stokely was being mobbed and so he'd
always be saying well you know was I too strong on this so what was I not strong enough or should
I have emphasized this or that and so it was like getting into like what's the messaging and what
is it we're trying to say but it's from the from the person who's at the very point of doing it you
know and so I mean that was a kind of unique spot and and just because of the again the
nag experience and I mean he knew that we were going to be both totally friendly and support
but also critical you know it's like you know you know we'll come back to Carmichael and his
vision that's Nick and put me to ask about the you were in Newark in July of 67
in fact I got to visit to Cleveland a week before my folks and my dad who never quite made that
radical stuff I remember he said oh you got back just in time to start the riot didn't you
yeah my dad unfortunately became who had been as I said earlier this conversation with great
inspiration for me as we the 60s progress we had less and less real conversation he just really
he couldn't go beyond the certain point and we had gone beyond that and the fact that his son
was doing it the first person the family who had a chance to complete a college education I dropped
out of school for 11 years we didn't go back until 75 which was after this time period we're talking
about it's after he died too he died 74 he just got he thought that was wasting my life he said are
you are you happy working for mr. Castro and just you know mr. this and this and
well that I guess to say that is to make that very important point that there are very substantial
personal costs that come in a life of commitment that you have left yeah yeah
the thing with my mother was funny she was also opposed to it a lot of the stuff but
and I used to come home and she she she always have this conversation but the way she'd look at me
she always could have looked at it was like him here up my hair afro and wasn't until
ebony magazine did a whole thing on the new cultural of the 60s in the afro that she finally
relented and said well as long as you cut it and keep it shaped it's all right you know but
but she was very much concerned with how the parents and how people think and stuff like that
is your reaction to Newark to Newark? Well I mean I think we participated you know I was out
of the streets to in the Newark rebellion we are actually as I said was part of this more racial
against the white power structure is well let's just say what happened I got back from Cleveland
I had just developed this friendship with a lady who was a vista volunteer and she was over in the
North Ward and she was from actually from well with New Jersey beach town further so and I'd
get over to visit her and I stayed until a little bit after midnight and I suddenly told
me I should go home back to the North I was living in the sensual ward on 18th Avenue and so I
as I was walking back at night as a very few cars out and then I was I heard police sirens and then I
heard cracks and stuff was a gunshot somebody shooting at somebody and so I kept walking back and
so I got back over to the 18th Ward I mean 80th Avenue in the sensual ward and people tell me the
whole all hell had broken loose and it broke and loose at the police station which was just one block
away from where I lived on 17th Avenue and where they had captured this guy forget his name now John
he was a taxi driver and they had put him inside and and the people were outside the police station
and then they said I'm throwing rocks and bricks and stuff like that and what happened is because
I lived the block away but more importantly and so I was right there at the scene is that there
was this guy named BJ and BJ was a community character who grew up in the sensual ward and the
minute I saw the movie Zorba the Greek that's BJ so if you ever saw that movie with the kind
of character Zorba was this is what BJ was and and he and I lived together because what happened is
we got an office in the sensual ward whose windows would get broken out by the local democrats
but right next door he had a place and I moved in remember we had a tub tub a tub right in the kitchen
and it was old fashioned but he knew everybody and so I mean my ability to be there and organize
and meet people and get accepted was through BJ and so when we went out that night on 17th Avenue
is like what's happening is he knew people I knew people but I knew people basically through him
and we said look looks like something big is happening here it's we heard it was spreading over on
springful Avenue which was one of the main streets and we said let's not try to stop this
but let's what we do is we're only going to attack things that are white-owned because we want to
get the white domination white ownership out of the black community and which forced a lot of
store owners to start saying even some white folks said put other windows black home black home
you know after they caught up on the second night or so but I guess what I'm say that is that we
didn't want to have people be seen go out go out while they do and stuff and is that we were
we had a very much of a clear intent and so this was even different within the stick because I remember
my friends in Detroit snake and basically told people to get off the streets and they had no street
and so we were right there actually got beat up by the police that night well the second night
because what happened is it's really stupid we were there were some housing projects right
near the 17th Avenue called the Hayes homes and I have no idea if they're still standing but I
saw a bunch of policemen and being cocky and young and totally stupid I yelled black power like
this was what was happening and they said stop right there so I had about less than two seconds
to figure out whether I could run fast enough to get into the projects because I knew once I got
the projects they never find me but the question is how would they chase me how fast their guns
could shoot how good so I decided well I think I'm going to stay here I'm not going to run
I'm not going to take that risk so all of a sudden I was with a guy from the neighborhood got
named Joe Whitley who was a bartender at a bar in the Central Ward and they stopped us and they
said now what did you say and these are eight really big guys they're all bigger than both me and Joe
and so in some of the squeaky voice I said black power because I couldn't recant when I had said
but you know this was totally intimidating they had guns and everything and so they grabbed us
and what was really interesting is both then and hindsight they beat us but what they did was
they used rubber trunches they didn't use anything that would leave marks and so they just came
and turned us around hit us hit us like this all this and what happened is this is where the
earlier civil rights training really paid off back of the non-violent days because I knew how to turn
and lean and you know so that they couldn't get in here and all that stuff and protect my head
and so I'll absorb some of the blows my friend Joe didn't so what happened is that they left us
there Joe was lying lying on the sidewalk you know I was on the sidewalk but I bounced up and
and so and I had to take him home essentially and then once I was really mad I did and so we ended up
going into one of the neighborhood bars and just and just take of course this is where the
looting part came in because all these beer kids people just say hey we're all the
the term was we're gonna liberate that you know take it over to my house we're gonna consume it but
so it was a very you know I could have gotten killed easily that night and then about two nights
later I was they could they had a curfew and so I was out past a curfew on South Florida Javanagh
and so I had to get in call on around some community resources to I didn't have cell phone
we've had cell phone them it wasn't great I gotta call a few people gotten so I just not
got a couple doors and I said I'm with the newer group and we've been working around you know black
support and so the rides and by power and could I stay here for a while and they let me in
if not I would have been out in the street there were snipers out in the street we actually knew
a couple of snipers who who were firing on the cops but we weren't doing that but I didn't want
to get caught in the middle of that either so I mean they let me in so that was the night that I
got saved and from being out in the street so there were several you know occasions like that
that you know will it happen during the North
and then sitting up in this and there were some older black woman I could hear in the back of them
they were talking about all the stuff that happened last night and she said it's about time they did
this they've been doing it around the country and it's about time to do it here and so that kept me
that our message and our campaigns of the six to eight months previous to that in terms of the
racial prologue rising around white control not necessarily just white people but with the white
control had had some positive effect because I remember in a couple other places Cleveland being one
of them at home time when they went to have the half-grabelian there was a very apologetic we just you know
we we we acted like animals we just overacted it that's why we made sure to say this was a rebellion
not just a riot making those distinctions in terms of the organizing so that people who had stood up
in a slightly unusual way you know felt that they had they at manifested something important and
and and feeling good good about it which is one of the reasons why the state police really felt that
we were had a real hand in promoting and being a part of the rebellion the massive police response
did you did you emerge from that it sounds as if you emerge from that five days
feeling more inspired by the example of this self assertion of black community you did
discouraged by the state's capacity to respond yes definitely in fact we were hoping the state
wouldn't have a good capacity to respond they would have put us in jail I guess that would have
probably probably some of the proper response or and of course they were of course all these
commissions that came afterwards they were set up I can't remember the big one in New Jersey to
investigate what had happened and why this had happened and etc etc etc but we felt that the
the go from so where do we want to go from there I mean because that's from the organizer's
standpoint okay we had the great mass revolt out in the street we did something totally unprecedented
and where do we go from now yeah so let's make this an opportunity to go for black political power
and it's out of that kid in the idea getting the black mayor and so we had begun this earlier on in
some ways in 1966 there has been a mayoral election yeah 66 yeah and we couldn't get quite
unity for for who should run for mayor of course from the black candidate and so George Richardson
who had been a state assemblyman and lived in the work wanted to run and so what he did was
but he wanted a power base kind of like Bill Nolan ever on the right to work they so instead of
running for mayor he wanted a power base so he ran for central war councilman and we and we put
up just like the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party put up the mock election for government back
in and what was that 63 as we did something for mayor we we said let's we have to have a black
mayoral candidate you get people thinking about voting for a black man for mayor so we found
this guy named Ken Gibson who was a civil engineer he seemed to be very he was middle class that
excessively but clearly that's where he came out of didn't have any great foreign policy policies
around a lot of stuff but didn't have any real guard I mean track record in a negative way either
and he hadn't antagonized many folks in the black community so we put up for him for black mayor
he lost but he got a credible amount of votes and and so what happened though in 1970
meaning after that is in Richard some decided he really wants to run for mayor and so does Gibson
now and so we that's why we had a political convention so that there would be a candidate that
comes out of the black community it's actually the black and Puerto Rican because we were at that time
being noticed that there were more and more Puerto Ricans living there was a woman named Ilda Ildago
who had been very supportive around a lot of the black causes and realizing that the Puerto Ricans
had more at stake with the black community there and so that there was that link early on so we had
this black and Puerto Rican convention and we nominated Ken Gibson for for mayor and then
that was early 70 I think I can't remember either late 69 early 70 and then of course the election
was in 70 and then he ran for mayor and one and I say the other side I don't total arrogance
there were four Italians who ran against them I mean they just assumed that they could
beat any black per candidate so they ran for them and of course they split the vote and Gibson
what easily
let me put you back to one other very significant outcome post July of 67
you will work with Nathan Wright to organize the first black convention
can you describe that process that effort to bring that together and what
the vision that animated that convention and what you saw looking at from the moment
well I think part of the vision was how do you go from community power to broader urban power
even taste of national power and stuff like that and how do we sit down the different parts of
the black community some of the more progressive black politicians some of the black business people
some of the folks who were going from that thing of being negro to being black did make them
rather revolutionaries but at least they were having progressive thinking of course you had
progressive music Motown Maverine Gay I was you hearing on the radio now was more
a wreath of Franklin was coming up from this period so it just seemed I mean we were going
over to the Apollo Theater every week weekend and over in New York and so it seemed like
there were a lot of things that were just coming falling together and so the vision we were
putting out was a different kind of black America that united different parts of the community
was in struggle against all forms of white domination and white control but as we were a
Jones in some ways I think summarized it in terms of more modern black nationalism which makes
them a little different and then others is that Newark is our battleground we're not talking about
Africa like Marcus Garvey we're not talking about the black world we may have some ideas on that
but that's not what we're spending any time working on and we're talking about how do we get black
power right below our feet and our feet are here in Newark and Jersey and so from a national
a more traditional nationals perspective he brought that he brought that in that the power also
brought in the nation of Islam as part of that and so we were able to talk this idea of what
was called the black United Front which is what Stokeley wanted to do in DC after he left his
chairman of SNCC in 67 and and and trying to build a unity around politics in the black community
which hadn't hadn't happened in modern times so that wasn't some ways the broader vision
and that but we needed candidates and working relationships at different levels which we
I mean we ended up traditional Baptist churches and did this and I always say the 60s was a period
when you could go from politically wanting to have a white I mean a hot dog next to a white person
the early 60s talking about mass revolution revolutionary politics all in the space of I mean
when you think about what happened in the 60s that all that continuum was just
amazing it's why particularly in the 70s and 80s you know it's like when that didn't exist in the
same way people were lost a lot of people who were activists were lost because it's like
well you know so much happened in that in that short time period
let me ask you if you would to describe your emergence through SNCC as SNCC's national director
and sub-ga well what happened increasingly as the years went on and both in terms of financial
resources listening some of which we helped we shot ourselves in the foot I think probably always
saying it's wrong I mean we when we came out of the answer the war in Vietnam just like Martin
Luther King's organization suffered some financial and as well as political repercussions
him probably more than we did because after the march in Washington he was seen as a national
black leader to great degree and people like Lyndon Johnson were seeing working with him and all
of a sudden he's now opposing the Vietnam War which is Johnson's War and the ramifications
of that on SCLC his group I think we're much more at least than on us we never were quite at that
lofty stand but still I mean there were people who didn't think I mean we're talking about civil
rights and now that's not the position that African Americans that's mostly in talking
for in policy that's a whole other section of the world that does that or the US government
of the US civil society the civil rights is about local domestic and black problem we are
going beyond that so that was we lost some money on that as well as some of the political support
got brought us closer to the anti-war movements and the peace movement to be sure but it lost
some of the mainstream people who really in terms of the 60s the Mississippi challenge and the
freedom party and the freedom schools in the city we had really you know God non to us
and then of and then in 66 thanks to a research paper by this one of our research people in
National SNCC got named Jack Minnes oh I always call him Jack Daniels drinking brilliant guy
he did a research paper on Israel and out of that determined that I mean that that that
not SNCC but that Israel was a Zionist country it was basically oppressing the people the
Palestinians and blah blah blah blah and SNCC people read it and supported so we basically came
out against Zionism and in Israel so that created a whole another stir of of concentration and
and particularly in the more liberal movements of the United States I remember in New York we had
at that time we had a newspaper and I was going to take the newspaper over to a meeting
community meeting and somewhere in Manhattan and I got there at the very end the meeting and people
were walking out of the door and I went up to the person who was chairing the media I said could I
make an announcement and then and I said I have the new newspaper I've stuck with the article on
Israel and Zionism people literally turned around who would walk out I got mob I mean that's
physically mob I mean it's people everybody wanted that paper because that was the issue and
and I was sold out in probably about five minutes and it was just that that that point and so
but that issue in in many ways reverberated us negatively in terms of the more broader
I mean the liberal movements of the time and is a thing between liberalism and radicalism not
just around Israel but Vietnam probably being more of a point thing and and then are you just for
peace are you for liberation of Vietnam that was another little side point within that debate as well
and we supported the national liberation front of the Vietnamese people and I did that even more
so I have to go ahead and keep it meeting some of them yeah yeah I'm joking I know your
process okay we're back
you mentioned the financial pressures that increasingly were really bad
yeah core was going through seven out two sure you've mentioned
the Israel tension you've mentioned the anti-war stuff if you haven't talked and I'd love to
get your perspective on the simultaneous negative consequences of say cool and tell pro and state
security and the whole can hang you come after pretty much all the hard of this
yeah I think we weren't totally aware of all of it at the time and I mean by the time the
panthers for example became more prominent it became much much clearer but we knew that there
were things that were happening people became aware of agents in the movement who were they how do
we recognize them what would they be doing what do we have that so sensitive that anybody
but particularly want and and trying to then come up well how do we deal with this how I mean
how do we develop a strategy you know for for dealing with internal agents then what do we talk
about so that was one piece of it another piece is that it just seemed that particularly FBI
and maybe co-entell Pro wasn't always clear to who was which was more interested in dividing the
black movement and and then trying to get people one by one from that so particularly when the
panthers started becoming a more of a prominent organization there were real attempts to pit the
panthers against Nick and so one of our key leaders in New Jersey you know came to us and said
you know I got a visit from the FBI and they came in the my house he said and he's got him
Irving Davis and they dropped $100 which was more than minutes today on my bed and said
we need to talk to you and we need to talk to us and we'll make it easier for you and hear some
money for you and he'd turn the down tell him to leave the house another time they would tell
people that the panthers were out to get us and that the panthers hadn't quite liked some of the things
we were saying this was another process of which is not about co-entell post so much as there was
this attempt to bring the two organizations together into either an alliance as we called it or
a merger as the panthers called it and this is the runner-up I'm gonna tell you I became
had a snake and Huey Newton and the panthers in S迪琪 had literally drafted on their own free
of our best known people Stokeley, Rap and James Foreman into their organization Stokeley was
drafted as a really creator a whole new position called Prime Minister this was 1967 and Foreman
was made the minister of foreign affairs and Rap was the minister of justice and there was a big
thing at Cuey's birthday party in February 17th here in Oakland and I think they did something
similar in LA where it was basically publicizing the former was there Stokeley was there he was by
this time the x-chair and Rap was technically the chair in February Rap couldn't travel because he
had been on this gun charge and he could only travel at all with his lawyer who was the late William
consular and and and there were a couple trips they went on one one I guess it was to LA because
Rap did was at that event so I guess Concler would live but so he was quite as able to travel Stokeley
and and Foreman but it was part of bringing us in but there were tensions and there's like well do
we agree with everything the panthers are saying do they agree with their style organization which is
beyond whether we think they're a great organization but are they our organization and do we want
to become panthers and most of us kind of were Luke Warmer that had best and some people were saying
and other folks were saying this is a historical opportunity hey we represent the more educated
intellectual folks the panthers represent the streets forests the brothers and sisters on the
street and this would be a historic alliance within a new organization but I think the feeling
was that we were getting eaten up or that was that was attempt and Eldridge Cleaver particularly
graffiti was in jail was the point person for a lot of this discussion and dialogue and I guess at
the meeting that I was made chairman of Stoke we voted on the Panther program and we said that
we thought it was a good program but it was not either our program or necessarily the the
revolutionary program and somehow they got back to the panthers and that of course and then that
a certain point when there was some more friction which got almost physical in some ways that we said
we can't be in a group with this county book so as chair of SNEC I said there's no there's
certainly no merger and there's not even a clear alliance and and then we spent some time in 68
and I get personally trying to work with local groups again the local focus of groups that
would have been inspired by what the panthers were doing but might have a slightly different
politics so in particular group I spent some time with what we call the black liberators
out in St. Louis in fact managed to get arrested with them and Bill Constellar had to come out
there and drag me out of jail though what was also really great was my uncle who's a lawyer
he wanted to join the legal team and he did he came in and to my horror they said that
they should record they should play the speech to the jury to see if the police were warranted
and the police had actually pulled out an old anti labor law called unlawful assembly which
had only been used back in the 30s it hadn't been used since then and that was what we were
arrested for unlawful assembly and I thought I said it's a pretty provocative thing in the speech
that night but the jury thought that it wasn't necessarily beyond the pale and we got off
yeah well I don't know maybe I hadn't thought about this a couple days I think I mean I can't
remember I mean I was a generally supportive of the of the uprisings and the were happening
around the country it was still 68 so there were still rebellions after Detroit and Newark
and I was supporting the people of the world the kind of the third-world concept that we were all
generally supportive of at that time and I don't even know if I said anything that specific about
St. Louis itself I can I probably tried to I like to try to make stuff more less abstract and
so I probably might have said something about the local officials but and then I remember I really
got pissed off because afterwards you get mobbed of course and there's really nice looking sister
who came up and said you know she liked to meet me and then there was a party later on that
was invited to so I was prepared to go to this party and meet the sister again and we ended up
getting arrested that read in the middle of the street and then sent to the workhouse
and that was interesting too because in many ways because we were known we were celebrities the
the prisoners cut treated us extremely well it was like being a mafia done in the prison
even the warden this is a black penitentiary and a place called Kinlock a little small
predominantly black town outside of St. Louis and I mean he let us go in and use this telephone
you know to talk to a national press or whoever and and the prisoners would come up and say hey man
I can get you a good sandwich tonight or or you smoke I even smoke but you know we get you some
cigarettes all that this is like we were big shit and of course the warden was afraid we were
organized the prisoners again stand before us and so he was nice for that that was why he was nice
so it was a little this aside experience but did you have confidence when you took the helmet
of the snack that you could so much was swirling there's so much volatility membership
staff finances relationships this old struggle with them all these things did you know
but what was your sense of the likelihood that you could be successful yeah well look at Obama
today after George Bush context no I actually did feel that way and yeah and I must admit it has
first a major depression for me in the some of the following years that I wasn't able to do more
than I could I mean looking back on it turns on my head in terms of rationality looking like you
say as you pose the question given what was going on uh snake was on a downright downward cycle pretty
whichever since 64 after after the in lighting city thing uh we did kind of revamp at 65 and did
some stuff stokely and took some folks to Alabama where we had a project that how that came the
lounge county organization so there was some motion but still people were leaving they were doing
other things and it was like almost kind of big even for people who were leaving for political
reasons so much it was like I've been in this battle too long the same as like being an award
and I need to do code do something else and maybe related but not here and so we were losing membership
losing money um and the meetings were getting dispirited this was a time when the white folks were
asked to leave and and so that became a whole another major issue in itself and so there was a lot
of this is even before I got there and uh but you know there was still an organization in 67 and 67
and 68 and um and I felt that we could turn it out of time maybe a different version and uh and
and my focus was to try again given my history and when I learned the snake and SDS it's
to get more digress towards level the snake was not going to be the organization that was always
the difference between the snake approach and the panther approach I mean the panther is going
around like a lot of groups like NAACP organizing chapters around the country uh and while we had
a couple chapters that was the when we organized something was always the people's thing so like
louvts county the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party Newark Community Union project stuff like that
because we knew at some level we were always going to leave and and so we had to have the real
ownership of this from the very beginning where the people and uh so that was really part of our
organizing thing and so uh in trying to do some type of national community unions focus of
grassroots unity it was not so much snake was doing this but it was basically joining with groups
that were kind of radical grassrootsy around the country black liberators and say loas uh
group called jomo and uh Jackson Jacksonville and Orlando uh Florida uh some folks out in LA
who would come out of the watch rebellion and um looking at groups like that you know who had
local base and traction in their own communities and who would be empowered by having national
connections national networks yeah the national consortium I mean whether that would become a
political party or what we never got to fidesc I mean but uh at least in one year that was that
generally my focus stoking at a little different focus and I mean he uh wanted to do this black
never front and idea which he tried to do in Washington and I guess had a little bit of attraction
while he was physically on the scene but in a certain level you're bringing together interest
that I really I'm not going to stay together uh maybe in a perfect world they might stay together
a little bit but you have this bigger world like the so-called white power elite and which will find
ways to if you do and you see the carrot or through the stick to pry people apart and say you
have other interests besides just joining up with a bunch of black radicals and that's generally
been what's happened around the country around that well part of the third world is the
the work he did in Cuba well part of the third world focus is that there were different places
around the world that we were generally supportive of and the idea of the Vence of Ramus Brigade
which interestingly enough still exists today one of the things I'm not that close to it any longer
but not for political reasons just many different things and it's more or younger people now who
kind of go is the idea of both meeting people in third world countries and we've been somewhat
inspired by the Abraham Lincoln Brigade and some of us wanted to go fight in Vietnam against the
United States and they eat in troops that was very rhetorical but that was the least the idea that
was put out there like just getting what's happened more recently this guy here locally I can't
think of his name now he's in jail who was supporting Al Qaeda and they have been jail now and
I can't John Howard something I can't remember his name but he's from Mill Valley over in the
ring so luckily that never happened and why's her head came down starting with the Vietnamese
themselves and they said you know there's someplace closer that is need your help and that
and you could do something where you don't need to actually have to physically fight because they've
actually been successful but they can use other kinds of help from you and that's Cuba and so that's
what that's that's that was a logic of what brought Cuba into our eyes away from Vietnam even in
the middle of the anti-Vietnam war and so some people who in the movements people from SDS
were representing the white movement some people from the Chicano movement which was developing
and the black movement and the pastors were too busy thankfully and so they said well somebody
from a section do it and when I've been share of Snick I had sent some people in delegation
to Cuba actually we sent one to North Korea we had sent one to Africa to Tanzania we had a
Pan-African skills program in Tanzania and Zimbabwe where we brought in people who have technical
skills of African-Americans to help in those countries so there was some president thinking about that
so we joined the National Committee and organized the first actually four brigades
and what happened to the first one what I mean the program which was part of the time the
propaganda of the time we're gonna bring 300 black people 300 brown people and 300 white people
to Cuba so 900 people turn that we there were 200 people who actually showed up for that first
one ceramispriade and most of them were white and we felt we had failed humans didn't think that
but we felt that because that was what we had projected and and also in hindsight even then we realized
that we had been a little bit off of kilter in our target but what we felt was it was important to
build the movements and see the brigades organizing arms so we organized for the second brigade which
was a march of 1970 and we had over 800 people there which was the biggest brigade ever I mean the
humans even though we had too many people not because we had too many people but because their
resources the houses take us around the fetus at the same time they were doing other things in Cuba
you know like there were 10 million 10 million times sugar harvest the year we were there is
it was just and they were in a rich country you know so so they couldn't do that so but the point
was we had made is that that there was a real enthusiasm in the movement and for this and
it did a lot of different things I mean what it did for me it took us out of the United States in a
way that we could look at the US movement in a more objective way so we have people sitting around
in the camps in Cuba where we're working and I'm meeting people from all over the country in a way
that I could never do that in the United States they could meet each other meeting people
different movements I mean sometimes our rhetoric was a little while and I was thinking one time
being the Cuban's shoe you have a bunch of African-Americans who said they want the the
Republic of New Africa we want the five states of the South then the Chicanos would come and talk
about us Laan and the Southwest this was going to be a the new Chicano nation and the Indians
were coming talk talking about you know taking over seven of the South it's like well is there
this space for all that happen what happens to the white people you know but that's our youthful
craziness but but we built some bonds both with the Cubans I mean I loved it that the Cubans would
basically cut sugar cane and work all day and then they could have parties and dance and drink rum
I mean it was a way some you can identify me the Russians I mean you could read about the Soviet
revolution and all the discipline and the Democratic Centralism and all that but it wasn't like well
that's not my revolution you know it's like was it was it who was it it's emigolences I can't dance
in my revolution this not going to be a revolution and and you felt the Cubans understood all that you
know there was this problem which wasn't big at the time I remember it came up around Grenada
about the God the spirituals of peace I remember some Grenadians who were really like the Cuban
model said that it wouldn't work in Cuba I mean in Grenada because you can have more God space for
God in our movement in our liberation force so that's it that's in the side but so we got a
sense of some some real people who had made a revolution and as real human beings who had real
problems people who had divorced their wives or what wives who became independent left their
husbands and and so some of the downsides but or the you know the continuing struggle people go
into meetings eight nights a week not seeing their kids on a regular basis their kids being school by
community and what happened my mom being my daddy you know kind of thing and so they're real it so
it wasn't glossed over so that was great got to learn certain things like when when we say 10
o'clock we mean 10 o'clock and this is a Latin country too you know you know we we're gonna have a
meeting the next day or later that day the Cubans are gonna say Campanierdos it is now 4 o'clock we
are gonna meet at six o'clock let's just let's synchronize our watches so we come here at six o'clock
because we're doing important business and that was something we we all have this thing called CP time
colored people's time black Latinos and it will show up the meeting starts with when we
when we show up and very lack of days ago form so the Cubans really help to stick that in terms of
if you're gonna be doing stuff for the people representing people on the people's time then you
need to have some degree of discipline so little things like that but also um meeting people
Cuba was a center for revolutionaries from all over the world so I mean I remember this guy
a guy named Ernesto from Angola and he we just met him at the Isle of Youth and he just talked
about his country and his struggle and one of the things I got from people like him and other people
was uh miss him Brazilians so at that time where uh had been couldn't be in Brazil uh as how well
we could talk about their whole country and I said you know I know people who can talk about Harlem
or some community folks who can talk about the south side or the west side or their town uh but can
they really talk about their state their country other cities in the country I mean do we have a
view of our country uh that's concrete and uh and uh and uh and uh and not just rhetorical then we
can actually talk about and so listening to those folks do that I mean gran and goal is smaller than
than the United States uh but I mean it's how do we develop the kind of learning and the discipline
to do that kind of thing uh I remember meeting with some of the Vietnamese this guy from Vietnam
and he said to me he says well what's the labor movement like in your country so my first
reaction was oh I just have a bunch of sellouts next question what's the labor movement about
in your country could you tell us a loud and detailed so in a two hours I mean he made me backstrag
and guessed through some of my stereotypes which are the progressive unions which are the non progressive
unions what makes them progressive what makes the others not progressive what's their constituency
what's their base uh is there possibly I mean their focus of course was in terms of what
groups in the labor movement might be more open to being anti-war activity but still the thinking
of how to dissect a whole movement beyond the little simple stuff that we were doing you know
what I saw a learning process is if you're going to meet with revolutionaries and be with revolutionaries
you know you basically have serious conversations based on real things and so that was real useful
I mean uh I had been kind of an organizer of the brigade and then the second brigade came the
third brigade came down later in the summer and so I remember asking the Cubans if I could stay on
for another couple months so I could actually enjoy the country so I was at the Haudela Libre
it's they called O'Hillton Hotel and one of the things I learned to like I say this now because
I was on their dime essentially is um it was fish I grew up in Cleveland no fresh fish around I
ate sardines that was that was my and maybe tuna fish sandwiches that was my idea of fish and
didn't all fish have these new bones that you might so one of the things I decided to do in the
Haudela Libre I said there's this fish here every day though what's interesting though is Cuba
big and island didn't have a fishing industry and it was only thanks to the Japanese uh who came
and showed them how to do uh refrigeration to make it something that they could do all over the island
uh because if you could get fish on obviously if you were rich or if you live right near the
coast and fix it that day but you couldn't take it inland and Cuba's a big fat island it's not you
know so there was never a real taste for fish on the island so that's a little story inside but
so I used to go out and get I said I wonder what hell about taste like I wonder with this taste
like it what's what's perched like and I can just do it and so it gave I mean that's a small piece but
but uh and then we had these wonderful meetings with the Vietnamese uh it's a conference that
never came out is that the Vietnamese wanted to organize anti-war conference so it invoked
folks from the United States and a few other countries and um it was gonna be in Cuba because that
was the place we had all access and I was asked along with a couple other folks actually
Abby Hoffman from the Yippee's was there and uh as part of the planning group and I guess I mean
with the Yippee's for the first time I mean I'd heard of him and I've seen him at the thing but
to actually be in hotel rooms with saying in the host tell where the Yippee's was I think in
itself that's another chapter somewhere it's a book um Jerry Hoffman but um you're talking to the Vietnamese
about what they were going through and how they viewed the world how they viewed the struggle
I remember after one day after some really serious intensive US bombing of North Vietnam
young Vietnamese brother says I can't meet with you today I'm just really feeling too anti-American
and it's really not about you please understand that but I just can't do this today and he just went
off and then he saw a couple days later and then you know this a lot of great great stuff I mean
the humanism comes out I remember we were telling a joke and there was a woman sitting there be it
the me as a woman and uh and I started to stop because I was gonna use a kind of a cusp word or
this stuff and he said oh no no mad at me so so she's liberated you can say that she know
and and uh and then just the physical thing like some of them been walking down holding hands with
each other and a way that you would not see outside the game movement which was still very new in the
United States uh there and I remember one time we we were going for a lunch thing and uh the and
as cafeteria staff was really crowded and and the Vietnamese guy was sitting down and I said well you
sit down and then he says well here you sit at my lap uh no I'm bigger than you I can't do this
two minutes and he had to slap we can't do this stop and he he was just cool with it you know so
but so it was just constant learning on some of your levels uh I'm just you just some to come to mind and
yeah yeah the struggle continues uh
aluta kon to nua as they say in Portuguese and uh it takes different phases you learn some things
you move forward and that's like and then uh the other side learn stuff I mean even the
work around immigration uh the different levels I mean the thing that we like about immigration is
that it's both a domestic issue and an international issue uh one very difference is that um and I say
a lot this way but you could talk about talking about them and now and I just came back from Georgia
in Atlanta where we were trying to do some work around this eight uh house bill 87 and we were
going to get the Alabama but we ran out of time so that's a that's a future trip but um
is that the logic of the sixties was that we were fighting against the racist segregationists
state governors state uh city local officials and we were basically fighting for our civil rights
which were national and we were basically one of the federal government to come in and take care
of these bad guys either through the national guard and necessary through uh deputizing that's
why we push with Robert Kennedy and John Kennedy and later with Johnson to come in because the
government was going to take care of this and live up we were forced to the government to live up to
its standards but we finally the immigration is that the government is not the savior it's the problem
and because there's a world system uh of giant corporations laws like uh NAFTA and these other
things that the United States as the major western power is on top of and that uh that the problems
that are spurring the mass migration and immigration um not just to the United States but
over the world are based on that type of unequal world level and so in terms of trying to fight
around against racism at a higher level uh fighting against economic corporations at a higher level
is we're running into the set of the system the system of uh some people in old days called
imperialism uh but economic globalization or whatever you want to call it that that that the
United States government is very much a part of and the part of the immigration problem as it gets
stated is we're only talking about one part of it we're talking about you know as a push pull
and what's happening is we're just talking about the people who come here and we are not talking
about the situation that that forces them to leave their countries and the role of the United
States government and other western governments and banks and corporations in that uh and that's
not stopping so you can't really stop the the immigration as it gets put out in the US press
unless you do both ends you just can't punish the people who come um or whether they come to England
or whether they come to two different parts within country or within country so anyway so I mean
there's a continuing learning and and and refining old concepts developing new concepts and but
still looking at the question uh which which to me is the how how does the race and class thing
come together and somewhat increasingly gender is part of that and uh in a way that we started
in the 60s and uh in the 70s and now in the 21st century is playing a major role.
I can't thank you enough that's just been a real honor for me with you.
Thank you so much. Okay thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture.